bonjour à tous ravi de vous retrouver
sur Public Sénat mercredi le parcours
législatif de la loi travail s'est
terminé comme il avait commencé
c'est-à-dire par le recours au 493 qui
permettait au gouvernement d'engager sa
responsabilité et de se passer du vote
des députés la veille le débat en
nouvelle lecture au Sénat avait
également été tronqué puisque les
sénateurs avait décidé d'adopter une
motion posant la question préalable
présentée par la majorité de la droite
et du centre qui permettait aux
sénateurs de directement rejeter le
texte à l'issue de la discussion
générale cela a été tout de même
l'occasion pour la ministre du Travail
de prendre une dernière fois la parole
myiamel comer qui a estimé que le texte
était juste et équilibré elle l'a
hardement défendu estimant aussi que ce
passage au Sénat permettait de mettre en
exerg les différences entre la droite et
la gauche qui ont de conceptions bien
distinctes du monde du travail de son
côté la droite sénatariale a largement
taclé la méthode adoptée par le
gouvernement un véritable antimanuel de
réforme selon le corapporteur les
républicains Jean-Baptiste Lemoine
tandis que le patron des sénateurs LR
Bruno retaillot lui a largement regretté
que les apports du Sénat n'ai pas été
conservés par le gouvernement et à
l'Assemblée nationale Bruno rotillot qui
a estimé qu'au fur et à mesure et bien
le gouvernement n'avait fait que
complexifier ce texte tout de suite donc
retour au débat c'était mardi dans
l'hémicycle monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Président de la commission
des affaires sociales messieurs les
rapporteurs mesdames les sénatrices
messieurs les sénateurs je viens une
nouvelle fois m'exprimer devant le Sénat
avec une ambition intacte celle d'abord
de porter au nom du gouvernement un
texte de progrès utile à notre économie
utile à nos concitoyens l'ambition
ensuite de nourrir une fois encore avec
vous un débat franc exigeant et
constructif affranchi de certaines
postures aussi convenu que stérile je
suis bien placé pour savoir que la
période dont nous sortons n'a pas été un
long fleuve tranquille elle a été
marquée par de fortes crispations et
même des violences dont je veux redire
ici qu'elles sont inacceptable et face
auquel tous les républicains doivent se
montrer ferm et soudés mais cette
fermeté ne peut pas ne doit pas confiner
à
l'intransigence c'est pourquoi en tant
que ministre du dialogue social j'ai ré
tout au long de ces dernières semaines
pour rechercher toujours avec tous mes
interlocuteurs le compromis le plus
abouti tout au long de ces dernières
semaines le gouvernement a consulté
largement les organisations syndicales
les organisations patronnales et de
jeunesse j'ai pris l'initiative le mois
dernier de relancer une nouvelle
discussion avec les syndicats marqué par
un fait nouveau le souhait de la CGT de
renouer le dialogue je précise qu'avec
tous les autres y compris forces
ouvrière le contact a toujours été
maintenu et que tous ont fait montre
d'ouverture j'en profite également pour
saluer le courage des syndicats dis
réformistes qui se sont fortement
impliqués tout au long de ces semaines
pour consolider le compromis trouvé
ensemble et défendre les avancé contenu
dans ce texte les échanges menés
jusqu'au bout ont conduit le
gouvernement à proposer de nouvelles
évolutions pour trouver le meilleur
équilibre possible je vais y revenir
mais dialoguer négocier ne veut pas dire
forcément s'accorder en tout point des
divergences existaient et elles
perdurent encore aujourd'hui et si des
divergen traversent le champ syndical
force est de constater que l'examen du
texte au sein de votre notre Assemblée a
aussi eu le mérite de mettre en lumière
deux conceptions du monde du travail et
du dialogue social bien distincte je le
dis l'esprit d'autant plus serein que
j'ai tenu dans mes échanges avec vous à
me départir de toute approche partisane
et à me laisser guider seulement par le
souci de l'intérêt général mais
l'approche gouvernementale et celle de
la majorité sénatoriale sont apparu à
bien des égards irréconciliables c'est
ainsi
ce qui ni l'existence d'un clivage entre
la gauche et la droite en sont ici pour
leur frais ainsi votre assemblée
s'est-elle d'abord empressée de mettre
fin au 35 he en s'attaquant
fondamentalement à l'idée que dans une
société avancé le temps social ne se
résume pas à la journée de travail cette
conception néglige la vie personnelle
les loisirs la famille ou l'engagement
associatif toutes ces aspirations de nos
concitoyens qui sont aussi le socle du
vivre ensemble nous non seulement nous
sanctuarisons évidemment les 35 heur
mais nous créons aussi par exemple un
droit à la déconnexion pour protéger la
vie personnelle à l'heure du numérique
nous nous créons un compte engagement
citoyen pour valoriser l'activité
associative de millions de français nous
nous préservons et nous améliorons les
congés qu'un salarié peut prendre à
l'occasion d'un mariage d'une naissance
ou d'un décès nous nous sanctuarisons le
compte de prévention de la pébilité
pour que ceux qui ont eu les carrières
les plus difficiles puissent s le désir
partir plutôt à la retraite ou être
formé parce que cela est juste cette
avancée certains ont souhaité la
supprimer nous ne pouvons souscrire à
cette vision la majorité sénatoriale a
souhaité promouvoir une vision aussi
très singulière du dialogue social nous
avons eu ce débat par exemple sur le
référendum à la main de l'employeur
comme si le meilleur dialogue social a
étit tout simplement celui qui permet
permettit de se passer des partenaires
sociaux nous nous soutenons les
syndicats et augmentons de 20 % leurs
moyens soutien que la majorité
cénatoriale a également rejeté nous nous
maintenons les seuils sociaux pour
garantir une représentation des salariés
dans les entreprises de plus de 11
salariés cette protection la droite
sénatoriale l'a encore supprimé votre
version du texte pardonnez-moi de le
rappel c'est aussi la suppression de la
garantie jeune pour nos concitoyens de
moins de 26 ans sans emploi
sans formation et en situation de
précarité alors même que les premiers
retours d'expérience sont très
encourageants pour certains d'entre vous
solidarité ne peut rimer qu'avec
assistana nous nous créons le compte
personnel d'activité pour que chacun
bénéficie de sécurité renforcée dans un
monde en mouvement et puisse être acteur
de son propre parcours professionnel et
nous créons avec cl wter le droit
universel à la formation nous créons
également des nouveaux droits pour les
collaborateurs des plateformes
numériques oui je l'assume nos visions
de la société divergent profondément et
les projets présidentiels de vos
candidats à la primaire l'illustreront
chaque jour davantage au cours des
prochains mois mais l'expression de nos
divergences ne m'a jamais fait basculer
dans le sectarisme et je veux ici saluer
à nouveau le travail tout à fait
important des trois rapporteurs monsieur
le mooine gabouti et fuissier et je
remercie au passage le travail fourni
également par les
administrateurs parce que ce travail
méritait considération j'ai chercher à
argumenter sur chacun des amendements
que vous avez présenté et ceux durant
les 80 heures de débat que nous avons eu
en séance publique j'ai toujours veillé
à faire preuve de la plus grande
ouverture lorsque les propositions et
les idées émanant de V ban permettaient
d'enrichir notre texte tout en
conservant sa philosophie profonde vous
dites et vous allez à nouveau le dire au
moment de défendre la question préalable
dans quelques instants que l'apport du
Sénat a disparu ce n'est pas vrai j'en
veux pour preuve les améliorations que
nos débats ont permis de trouver
notamment par exemple sur les questions
de handicap nous partageons tous j'en
suis convaincu cette priorité mais des
améliorations il y en a eu aussi en
matière de groupement d'employeurs de
travail détaché de culture du dialogue
social sur tous ces thèmes je vous suis
reconnaissante d'avoir contribué à
l'enrichissement de ce texte je veux à
ce stade saluer plus largement
l'implication de l'ensemble des groupes
politiques du Sénat sur ce texte et
singulièrement également celle des
groupes CRC écologistes et RDSE
également enfin évidemment un vif
remerciement doit être adressé au groupe
socialiste et en
particulier à Nicole brick inlassable
défenseur de ce
texte
qui a su argumenter avec talent et
grande précision en faveur de cette
réforme merci au président du groupe
socialiste Didier Guillaume il y a des
présidents de groupe qui soutiennent
motivent participent à la bataille des
idées qu'il croi juste merci de votre
soutien constant président Guillaume
c'était dans la tempête un soutien que
je n'oublie
toutefois toutefois je le dis et le
redis ici avec détermination
entre le statu qu dont personne ne pense
qu'il est souhaitable et certaines
surenchèr libéral il existe une autre
voie celle d'un progrès négocié qui fait
confiance au terrain et aux partenaires
sociaux pour trouver les compromis les
plus efficaces et les plus justes le
triptique de cette loi ne sera donc pas
remis en cause car c'est le socle du
progrès économique social et
démocratique que nous voulons construire
de quoi s'agit-il tout d'abord de
renforcer la démocratie dans
l'entreprise car c'est ce qui permettra
de combiner le développement de
l'activité et de l'emploi et les
avancées sociales pour les salariés
ensuite de donner plus de souplesse et
de visibilité à nos entreprises en
particulier les plus petites pour
développer l'activité et l'emploi
durable enfin et surtout il s'agit
d'inventer la protection sociale du 21e
siècle en posant les bases d'une vraie
sécurité sociale professionnelle au cœur
de nos débats depuis des semaines il y a
la place que nous souhaitons accorder à
la négociation d'entreprise ce débat
nous le savons dépasse largement
d'ailleurs le cadre du Parlement et
traverse aussi le champ syndical le
président de la République l'a rappelé
avec force et conviction dans son
interview du 14 juillet dernier ce débat
en réalité il rythme notre histoire
depuis 1982 et alors que la gauche
engageait son œuvre de décentralisation
Jean rou déclaré citoyens dans la cité
les travailleurs doivent l'être aussi
dans leur
entreprise dans le prolongement de ces
débats certains aujourd'hui pour
discréditer le dialogue social dans
l'entreprise ont agité un épouvantaille
l'inversion de la hiérarchie des normes
ce procès je le dis avec force et sans
fondement cette loi s'inscrit dans la
continuité des lois votées depuis 1982
depuis
1998 depuis 2012 qui donne la priorité à
la proximité à la démocratie dans
l'entreprise aux salariés et à leurs
représentants que disons-nous que les
acteurs de terrain sont les mieux placés
pour négocier des accords qui tiennent
compte à la fois des besoins des
entreprises et des aspirations des
salariés n'est-ce pas ainsi que déjà
nous avons procédé dans la mise en œuvre
des 35 he
en tenant compte de la réalité de chaque
entreprise et des choix des partenaires
sociaux la loi doit protéger évidemment
mais la loi venue d'en haut ne sait pas
ne sait plus traiter de chaque situation
particulière de façon juste et efficace
nous parce que nous sommes réformistes
nous n'avons pas renoncé à notre
ambition de changer la société mais pour
changer la société plus que jamais il
faut agir par le haut et par le bas nous
avons décentralisé la République avec
succès à nous décentraliser aussi la
démocratie sociale pour autant le
gouvernement a entendu des
questionnements sincères et l'expression
de crainte de dumping social ces
craintes nous ne les partageons pas et
si nous avions une seule seconde
considérer que ce risque de dumping
pouvait être encouragé à travers ce
texte de loi nous ne l'aurions
évidemment jamais défendu mais cette
crainte nous ne l' prenons pas à la
légère et nous avons souhaité y répondre
à ceux qui l'expriment je veux d'abord
dire que cette menace a été brandi à
chaque fois à chaque fois que le
législateur a élargi le champ des
accords d'entreprise et elle ne s'est
pas concrétisé à ceux qui prétendent y
répondre par un renforcement du rôle des
branches je veux toutefois dire trois
choses premièrement n'idéalisons pas la
réalité actuelle des branches car
beaucoup d'entre elles ne fonctionnent
pas bien et qui n'apporte pas au
salariés les garanties qu'ils sont en
droit d'en attendre 42 branches fixent
même des montants de rémunération
inférieur au SMIC il faut que chacun ici
en ait aussi conscience
deuxièmement justement pour répondre au
manque de dynamisme des branche cette
loi veut les renforcer en réaffirmant
leur rôle de régulation et en procédant
à leur rationalisation pour passer de
700 à 300 en 400 en 4 ans pardon nous
n'avons jamais opposé les des différents
niveaux de régulation au contraire
accord d'entreprise convention
collective code du travail doivent
demeurer les piliers d'une démocratie
sociale moderne dynamique et génératrice
de progrès troisièmement après le
dernier tour de table avec les syndicats
organisés sous l'égide du Premier
ministre le mois dernier nous avons
souhaité prendre en compte certaines
considération c'est ainsi que nous nous
sommes déclarés prêts à pousser plus
loin le point d'équilibre à travers
trois nouvelles dispositions qui
figurent dans la dernière version du
projet de loi d'abord en définissant un
ordre conventionnel de branche
aujourd'hui il existe des domaines où
les accords de branche priment et
d'autres ce sont au contraire les
accords d'entreprise qui l'emportent et
il en existe d'autres où aucun principe
n'est fixé pour cela les partenaires
sociaux devront se prononcer et définir
les thèmes pour lesquels il ne sera pas
possible de déroger aux accords de
branche ensuite en confortant le
principe de faveur au niveau de la
branche sur toutes les questions de
pénibilité et d'égalité
professionnelle nous nous n'pposons pas
souplesse et régulation bien au
contraire nous affirmons qu'une
démocratie sociale moderne et efficace
avance sur ces deux jambesl enfin une
troisième disposition vise à tirer les
leçons de la séquence et à garantir les
troites associations des partenaires
sociaux pour la suite
même si je le rappelle ces derniers ont
refusé à l'automne dernier d'engager une
négociation autour du rapport comrexel
je confierai au Haut Conseil du dialogue
social qui rassemble l'ensemble des
partenaires sociaux la tâche de formuler
des propositions à la Commission de
refondation du Code du travail puisque
chacun admet la nécessité de faire
évoluer notre législation que chacun y
contribue de façon responsable et
constructive pour pour aboutir d'ici
2019 selon l'échéance prévue par ce
projet de
loi vous le savez ce texte a été l'otage
de considération fort éloigné de son
objet c'est ainsi cela n'entame en rien
ma détermination cela n'affaiblit en
rien mes convictions qui peut prétendre
qu'une loi qui renforce nos entreprises
qui renforce nos syndicat qui renforce
les protections des salariés ne sert pas
le progrès social nous pensons avoir
recherché et trouvé après des semaines
de discussion et malgré un contexte
tendu le point d'équilibre le plus juste
celui qui respecte le compromis passé
avec les syndicats du réformistes mais
qui démontre notre volonté de tenir
compte du point de vue de ceux qui ont
souhaité voir réaffirmer le poids des
branches lorsque les débats se seront
apaiser lorsque les dispositions de ce
texte seront entré dans le quotidien des
entreprises le quotidien de nos
concitoyens lorsqu'elles auront montré
le bénéfice que notre pays pouvait en
tirer nul doute que notre démocratie
sociale aura gagné en sérénité et en
efficacité nous ne légiférons pas pour
nousmême mais avec comme seu boussole
l'intérêt général l'amélioration de la
vie de nos concitoyens le redressement
de notre pays et avec à l'esprit une
perspective que ses assemblée ne perd
que rarement de vue le temps long plutôt
que le vacarme du temps présent je vous
remercie
merci merci Madame la
Ministre la parole est
maintenant à Jean-Baptiste le mooine
rapporteur de la commission des affaires
sociales et pour 5 minutes vous avez la
parole monsieur le
rapporteur merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
monsieur le Président de la Commission
mes chers collègues tout ça pour ça le
gouvernement a réussi en 5 mois à faire
en sorte que son texte ne satisfasse
quasiment plus personne il ne satisfait
pas une majorité d'organisations
représentatives de salariés comme il ne
satisfait pas non plus les organisations
représentativ d'employeurs il ne
satisfait pas la droite et le centre qui
pourtant dès le 15 février avait dit
leur totale disponibilité à vous
accompagner sur le chemin d'une réforme
ambitieuse il ne satisfait pas non plus
une partie de votre majorité qui ici a
longuement ferraillé sur les bancs du
groupe socialiste mais aussi sur les
bans du groupe communiste ou écologiste
contre le projet de loi et ne nous
faites pas le coup de croire Madame la
Ministre que c'est précisément parce que
personne n'est content que vous avez
trouvé le bon
équilibre alors nous allons abréger ce
tourment que vous faites subir au pays
car les Français sont là de ces blocages
de ces troubles à répétition qui ont été
constaté autour des manifestations tout
cela a un impact sur notre économie qui
risque de rester à l'écart de la reprise
européenne les images d'un véhicule de
policier attaqué ou de l'hôpital pour
enfants à nquer sont toujours présentes
dans les esprits c'est pourquoi avec mes
collègues Jean-Marc gabouti et Michel
fuissier avec lesquels nous avons bien
travaillé nous avons proposé lors de la
réunion de la commission des affaires
sociales le rejet du présent projet de
loi la Commission a donc adopté le
principe d'une question préalable qui
vous sera présentée dans quelques
instants par le président Milon certes
le débat au Sénat fut approfondi comme
le souhaitait le président Larcher
chacun a pu mesurer qu'il a permis
d'échanger des arguments et des idées
pour tenter d'améliorer ce marché du
travail français compte tenu de la cause
pour laquelle vous étiez commise
d'office madame la ministre vous méritez
bien sûr notre respect vous l'avez fait
avec dignité courtoisie mais il n'était
pas facile de faire la pédagogie d'un
texte aux équilibres imparfait c'était
mission impossible pour reprendre le
titre d'un film célèbre ces
remerciements s'adressent également à
chacun des collègues qui ont pris la
parole en tentant d'apporter leur part
de vérité sur des sujets lourds souvent
complexe et notamment au porte-parole
des groupes madame de roche madame brick
madame Laborde monsieur van lenberg
Cadic de zessard vatrin Madame Cohen et
donc au total malgré ces débats riches à
l'heure de faire le bilan les principaux
apports du Sénat n'ont pas été repris
par l'Assemblée nationale dans le texte
sur lequel le gouvernement a engagé pour
la deuxième fois sa
responsabilité aucune des modifications
sénatoriales à l'article 1er n'a trouvé
grâce aux yeux des députés alors nous
avions insisté sur l'objectif de
simplification poursuivi par la
Commission de refondation du code du
travail et nous avions renforcé
également le contrôle du Parlement à
l'article 2 dont nous partageons la
philosophie basée sur la subsidiarité
chè à la fois à Léon XI comme à pierre-
Joseph proudon et la primeuté de lacord
d'entreprise nous en sommes à l'origine
avec les lois de 2004 et de 2008 et donc
nous sommes heureux de voir que vous y
venez vous aussi les députés ont donc
malgré tout opposé une fin de non
recevoir à nos modif i des règles de la
durée légale hebdomadaire de travail un
amendement porté par le président
retaillot et de nombreux collègues alors
que ce n'était ni plus ni moins que la
logique de l'article 2 poussé au bout de
sa cohérence pour laisser les acteurs
sur le terrain décider de ce qui est bon
pour eux de plus à l'article 10 qui est
en quelque sorte le miroir de l'article
2 vous avez maintenu des règles de
validité des accords telles que bien peu
d'accords risque de voir le jour 50 %
d'un coup d'un seul la plupart du temps
ce serait inatteignable c'est pas moi
qui le dis sont les DRH sont les
organisations sociales les partenaires
sociaux encore une fois tout ça pour ça
alors oui les quelques avancées esquissé
dans le texte risque de rester virtuel
écrite certes au Joo madame la ministre
mais pas mise en œuvre nous avions par
ailleurs aménagé les règles des accords
de préservation et développement de
l'emploi pour en faire de puissants
outils d'adaptation interne des
entreprises certes la disposition
relative à la clause de retour à
meilleure fortune que nous avions
justement introduit pour marquer notre
attachement à ce que les efforts des
salariés soient récompensés par le le
versement d'une sorte de dividende
demeure mais vous l'avez rendu
facultative alors au total nous vous
proposions d'agir vite et fort et du
coup c'est un sentiment de déception qui
prévaut à la lecture du texte transmis
par les députés nous en tirons en
revanche un précieux retour d'expérience
pas besoin de lire un quelconque manuel
d'antiréforme pour savoir ce qu'il ne
faut pas faire il s'est écrit tout seul
au fil des semaines et des
reculades bref grâce au travail
approfondi qui était mené ici au Sénat
par la majorité sénatoriale dans toutes
ses composantes nous sommes prêts prêts
à proposer un nouveau contrat social au
pays un nouveau contrat social qui
libère les énergies et fasse vraiment
confiance aux acteurs sur le terrain un
nouveau contrat social qui table sur
l'alliance du capital et du travail et
non pas sur leur opposition un nouveau
contrat social qui fasse la par belle à
l'association des salariés au résultat
de leurs entreprise grâce à la
participation bref un autre monde du
travail est possible et c'est nous qui
vous le disons je vous remercie
merci merci monsieur le
rapporteur la parole est maintenant
notre collègue Jean-Marc gabouti
rapporteur de la commission des affaires
sociales vous avez la parole monsieur le
rapporteur monsieur le Président Madame
la ministre mes chers collègues
l'analyse des modifications apportées
par l'Assemblée nationale en nouvelle
lecture à l'ensemble du texte adopté par
le en particulier aux articles dont j'ai
eu la charge représent une véritable
déception nous sommes bien évidemment en
mesure de comprendre que le gouvernement
n'était pas prêt à retenir tous les
éléments introduits par le Sénat en
première lecture cependant à l'exception
de quelques sujets consensuel et de
quelques mesures techniques nous
regrettons dans l'esprit même du texte
d'origine que l'assemblée national et
son rapporteur ainsi que le gouvernement
n'it pas exprimé la moindre intention de
rechercher avec le Sénat l'amélioration
de mesures concrètes dans le sens de la
simplification et d'une plus grande
efficacité ainsi ce texte se trouve
encombré de dispositions ayant une
faible valeur normative parfois compuse
souvent inutile ou inapplicable il en
est notamment ainsi de la responsabilité
sociale des plateformes du droit à la
déconnexion des règles relatives à la
reconduction des contrats saisonniers et
de la création d'une de dialogue social
dans les réseaux de franchise concernant
le droit à la déconnexion les députés
ont réintroduit les dispositions peu
normatives que nous avions supprimé et
ils ont imprudemment élargi l'obligation
d'élaborer une charte sur ce sujet à
toutes les entreprises sans distinction
de taille y compris les TPE ce qui
manque notoirement de réalisme
s'agissant de la responsabilité des
plateformes de mise en relation
éectronique à l'égard de leurs
collaborateurs indépendants les députés
ont malheureusement rétabli leur
rédaction contestée tout en aménageant
les règles relatives à la couverture du
risque d'accident du travail ils ont
également supprimé la disposition sur la
présomption de non salariat pour ces
travailleurs compte tenu des difficultés
juridiques qu'elle aurait entraîné et se
montrant ainsi sensible à nos arguments
mais c'est surtout le rétablissement de
l'instance de dialogue social du réseau
de franchise qui paraît le plus
incompréhensible car même si le
dispositif a été aménagé en nouvelle
lecture il méconnaît toujours la nature
des relations qui existent entre le
franchiseur les franchisés et les
salariés de ces dernier nous avions
également réécrit les dispositions
relatives au licenciement économique
dont la rédaction issue des travaux de
l'Assemblée nationale en première
lecture a fait l'objet de vives critique
de la part de la majorité des
partenaires sociaux et des personnes que
nous avions
auditionné la version sénatoriale qui
visait à sécuriser juridiquement ce type
de licenciement et encadrer les recours
devant le juge a toutefois été rejeté en
bloc par les députés y compris la notion
essentielle et objectif de faisceau
d'indice pour définir une entreprise en
difficulté les députés ont par ailleurs
repoussé notre proposition créant un
véritable rcrit social pour toutes les
entreprises et celle obligeant les
partenaires sociaux à prévoir des
stipulations spécifiques en faveur des
petites entreprises dans tout accord de
branche même non étendu je suis pourtant
convaincu que les accords types négociés
par les branches peuvent être un
puissant levier de modernisation sociale
pour les petites
entreprises je note à cette occasion que
toutes les propositions introduites au
Sénat à l'initiative de la délégation
aux entreprises ont été rejeté par
l'Assemblée nationale à ce niveau ce
n'est plus une différence politique mais
une différence de culture qui témoigne
d'une véritable déconnexion entre la
gauche gouvernementale et le monde de
l'entreprise s'agissant de la médecine
du travail les députés ont partagé nos
préoccupations pour rationaliser les
visites des salariés en contrat courourt
améliorer le suivi des travailleurs de
nuit que vous avez proposé en amendement
et maintenir les règles de gouvernance
actuelles des services de santé au
travail mais ces avancées ne sauraient
masquer la suppression de la visite
d'aptitude obligatoire l'abandon de la
création d'une procédure d'appel des
avis d'aptitude devant une commission
régionale de médecin du travail ou
encore le rejet des modif des règles en
matière de responsabilité civile et
pénale de
l'employeur ce texte qui ne donne
satisfaction à personne apparaît sur ce
sur ce sujet plus comme un réaménagement
de façade comme que comme un traitement
de fond de ce sujet sensible en
conclusion le texte transmis par
l'Assemblée nationale en nouvelle
lecture et qui est parfois en
contradiction avec les objectifs
initialement affichés a profondément
modifié le le résultat de nos
délibérations et l'attitude du
gouvernement comme celle des députés ne
nous incite pas à espérer qu'une
nouvelle lecture du texte au Sénat
puisse modifier leur appréciation de nos
travaux je vous remercie merci monsieur
le
rapporteur la parole est maintenant à
notre collègue Michel fuicier rapporteur
de la commission des affaires
sociales pour 5
minutes
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
monsieur le président de la commission
des affaires sociales mes chers
collègues et surtout mes chers collègues
co-rapporteurs conscient des enjeux liés
à une meilleure sécurisation des
parcours professionnels des actifs le
Sénat avait adopté en première lecture
une approche pragmatique des
dispositions concernées échaudé par les
exemples récents du compte personnel de
formation le CPF et surtout du compte
pénibilité nous avions qui depuis plus
de 2 ans après sa création reste
inapplicable nous avions proposé dans un
premier temps de retirer les principales
sources de complexité du compte
personnel d'activité CPA les députés ont
malheureusement privilégier un affichage
politique sur les contraintes
antiéconomiques quand entraîne une
entrée en vigueur du dispositif dès le
1er janvier prochain à nos yeux la
problématique de la valorisation de
l'engagement citoyen mérite une
réflexion beaucoup plus approfondie que
la création du compte d'engagement
citoyen CEC proposé par le gouvernement
en effet ce nouveau compte regroupe des
formes d'engagement civique
professionnel ou citoyens qui ont bien
peu en commun la participation à la
réserve sanitaire Estelle assimilable
tutorat d'un apprenti en apprentis ou un
activité associative locale aussi
altruiste soit-elle enfin l'évaluation
du coût de son volet associatif et du
nombre de bénéficiires potentiels se
révèle lacunaire en raison de
l'élargissement de son périmètre en
cours d'examen parlementaire sans étude
approfondies de même il nous semblait
logique que ce compte personnel
d'activité soit clos lorsque son
titulaire cesse son activité profession
c'est-à-dire lorsqu'il liquide
l'ensemble des doigts à la retraite
enfin nous proposions de simplifier le
compte pénibilité afin de répondre aux
nombreuses inquiétudes des employeurs je
regrette que nous n'ayons pas été
entendus sur ces points et j'ai de
fortes craintes sur l'effectivité de la
mise en œuvre à comptter du 1er janvier
prochain du CPA concernant le reste
dispositions relative à la formation
professionnelle on peut néanmoins noter
que l'assemblée nation a adopté conforme
plusieurs articles introduits au Sénat
notamment celui relatif au CPF des
travailleurs des essat et approuvé nos
indispensables aménagements sur la
collecte de la contribution à la
formation professionnelle des non
salariés en revanche les députés n'ont
manifestement pas la même volonté que
nous de faire de l'apprentissage une
voie de réussite alors que le projet de
loi initial est quasiment muet sur cette
problématique le Sénat avait introduit
20 articles visant à surmonter les
obstacles qui freinent aujourd'hui son
développement et a amélioré le statut
des apprentis aucun de n'a été retenu
par les députés pas même l'obligation
pour les entreprises d'assurer la
formation des maîtres d'apprentissage et
a priori tout le monde était
d'accord il était pourtant le fruit
d'une longue concertation avec toutes
les parties impliquées dans la gouver et
le bon fonctionnement de cette voie de
formation aucune proposition alternative
n'a été présentée et l'Assemblée
nationale comme le gouvernement semble
se satisfaire du statico en la matière
alors que le model français est à bout
de souffle surtout si on le compare au
dynamisme de nos voisins sans nous
opposer sur le fond à la garantie jeune
nous avions estimé que
l'expérimentation devait être poursuivie
jusqu'à son terme l'Assemblée nationale
a rétabli cette généralisation une fois
encore le législateur renonce ici à
s'appuyer dans ses choix sur
l'évaluation d'une politique publique
innovante pour des raisons d'affichage
politique en période électorale enfin
l'Assemblée nationale a réintroduit les
dispositions dépourvues de porté
normative relativ à la validation des
acquis de l'expérience que nous avions
bien entendu supprimé tout comme elle a
préservé dans sa demande de rapport sur
la prolongation des emplois d'avenir qui
ne sont on le sait tous bien pourtant
pas la solution au chômage des jeunes au
final je regrette surtout que le
gouvernement et l'Assemblée nationale
n'ai pas saisi l'opportunité que notre
majorité sénatoriale sans doute la
dernière du quinquena de faire de
l'apprentissage une voie de réussite je
vous remercie merci monsieur le
rapporteur
nous allons passer à l'examen de la
motion tendant à opposer l'exception de
d'irrecevabilité Monsieur Dominique
vatrin notre collègue les membres du
groupe communiste républicain et
citoyens ont déposé une motion
distribuée sous le numéro 19 tendant à
opposer l'exception
d'irrecevabilité au texte en discussion
je rappelle que en application de
l'article 44 de notre règlement seul
droit à la parole l'auteur de
l'initiative son représentant et ce pour
10 minutes un orateur d'opinion
contraire pour 10 minutes le président
ou le rapporteur de la Commission saisie
au fond et le gouvernement je vais donc
appeler Madame Annie David qui va
défendre la
motion présenté par les membres du
groupe communiste républicain et
citoyens et ce pour 10 minutes vous avez
la parole ma cher collègue
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre mes chers collègues nous nous
apprêtons à examiner en nouvelle lecture
un texte qui sera adopté en force avec
des dispositions voulues par votre
gouvernement mais sans majorité de
gauche à l'Assemblée nationale un texte
qui n'est d'ailleurs pas non plus voulu
par une majorité de nos concitoyennes et
concitoyens pourtant profondément
attaché au droit social qui est le droit
de la vie du quotidien c'est bien la
raison pour laquelle la mobilisation est
si forte contre votre pojet signature en
masse de pétitions grève manifestations
dans les rues expression sur les réseaux
sociaux ce sont autant de témoignages de
l'attachement au travail et aux règles
qui le régissent de tout un peuple qui
vous demande de retirer ce texte mais à
l'évidence madame la ministre vous ne
les avez pas entendus les salariés et
leurs représentants sont en droit de
participer au débat sur ces sujets comme
à tous les sujets qui les concernent
à cet instant j'adresse mon soutien
plein et entier au salariés de la
société écoplat situé à Saint-Vincent de
mercuse dans mon département afin que le
jugement en cours de délibération soit
en leur faveur pour que la scope
etcoplascope puisse voir le jour et
ainsi leur permettre de préserver tout à
la fois leur emploi et leur savoir-faire
unique en France leur combat est
exemplaire contrairement à leur
employeur qui est parti en emportant la
caisse leur slogan est simple notre ami
c'est l'emploi etcoplascope vivra je
voulais que leur voix raisonne dans cet
hémicycle madame la ministre pour que
vous les entendiez et pour que vous leur
apportiez votre
soutien quant à votre texte essentiel
pour le quotidien des salariés il va
être adopté sans avoir été débattu à
l'Assemblée nationale tandis que
l'ensemble des propositions faites par
le Sénat les rapporteur viennent de le
rappeler ont été supprimés droit
d'amendement bafoué et refus de battre
en séance publique seront ces marques de
fabrique en première lecture lorsque
nous avions déposé cette même motion
monsieur capo canellaa nous rejoignait
sur la recevabilité discutable de ce
texte présenté au Parlement sans avoir
fait l'objet d'une concertation avec les
partenaires sociaux il s'y opposait
cependant au motif qu'elle aurait privé
le Sénat d'un débat utile et de toute
possibilité d'expression qu'en est-il
aujourd'hui mes chers collègues du
groupe udi UC alors que le débat a bien
eu lieu mais qu'aucune de vos
propositions n'a été retenue quant à
Madame brick elle affirmait en première
lecture que je la cite nous sommes des
parlementaires et ne pas débattre de ce
projet de loi constituerait un dénis de
nos responsabilités maintenez-vous ses
propos après deux adoptions au 493 à
l'Assemblée nationale à ce sujet j'en
profite pour rappeler que contrairement
à ce que prévoit la Constitution aucune
délibération en Conseil des ministres
n'est venue avaliser la deè utilisation
du 493 cela renforce nos doutes sur la
constitutionnalité de ce texte en
l'occurrence sur sa procédure d'adoption
un autre élément questionne le non
respect par le gouvernement de l'article
1 du Code du travail et notre président
ah il est plus là Gérard Larché j'allais
dire le connaît particulièrement puisque
c'est le sien l'article 1 du Code du
travail stipulant que tout projet de
réforme envisagé par le gouvernement qui
porte sur les relations individuelles et
collectives du travail l'emploi et la
formation professionnelle fait l'objet
d'une concertation préalable avec les
organisation syndical de salariés et
d'employeurs en première lecture vous
nous aviez répondu madame la ministre
avoir invité les partenaires sociaux à
des négociations sur le rapport
combrexcel ou encore sur le compte
personnel d'activité or c'est bien le
projet de loi qui est mentionné dans le
code du travail c'est donc le texte dans
son ensemble qui aurait dû faire l'objet
d'une concertation avec les partenaires
sociaux et nous savons toutes et tous
ici que cela n'a pas été fait et que ce
texte est donc sur la forme
irrecevable sur le fond ensuite comme
indiqué en première lecture nous
estimons que ce texte est contraire à la
Constitution et à notre histoire
juridique en effet pour garantir
l'égalité des citoyennes et des citoyens
la loi expression de la volonté du
peuple souverain s'est imposé par
rapport au contrat ainsi l'article
article 34 de la Constitution qui
définit les domaines d'intervention du
pouvoir législatif fonde le droit du
travail et le droit syndicale sur la loi
or l'inversion de la hiérarchie des
normes colonne vertébrale de votre
projet de loi que vous avez de nouveau
réaffirmé à l'instant madame la ministre
est contraire aux stipulations de cet
article sur lequel le Conseil
constitutionnel s'appuie régulièrement
ce dernier n'accepte que par exception
les transferts de compét de la loi vers
les accords d'entreprise de même sa
jurisprudence établie en 2004 et 2008
censure tout renvoie à l'accord
d'entreprise de dispositions relevant de
la Constitution comme le droit au repos
sans compter qu'audelà des aspects
purement juridiques ce sont les valeurs
de notre République laïque démocratique
et social que vous bafouez oubliant
ainsi que la République est sociale
grâce aux luttes syndicales et
populaires qui ont émaillé notre
histoire aujourd'hui vous reniez cet
héritage historique tout en
disqualifiant celles et ceux qui
poursuivent ce combat progressiste en
manifestant dans les rues comme la
Constitution leur en donne pourtant le
droit l'inversion de la hiérarchie des
normes n'est pas le seul point qui pose
problème d'un point de vue juridique les
ACC les accords en faveur de l'emploi
portent atteinte à la liberté
contractuelle puisque l'employeur peut
imposer une modification du contrat sans
avoir à se justifier je citeraai
également les dispositions relatives au
licenciement économique qui varient
selon la taille de l'entreprise en plus
d'être contraire au principe d'égalité
devant la loi cette modulation ne
s'appuie en rien sur la la réalité des
entreprises la taille de l'entreprise
n'est pas nécessairement lié à sa
situation économique enfin j'aimerais
insister sur le fait que vous remettez
en cause nos engagements internationaux
tout d'abord ce fixé par l'Organisation
internationale du travail oit en 2012 le
comité de la liberté syndicale de l'OIT
jugeait une affaire très similaire au
sujet d'une réforme menée en Grèce et
certainement pensé comme c'est le cas en
France dans un bureau de la Commission
européenne voici un extrait des
conclusions du Comité de
l'OIT la mise en place de procédures
favorisant systématiquement la
négociation décentralisée de
dispositions dérogatoires dans un sens
moins favorable que les dispositions de
niveau supérieur peut conduire à des
stabil globalement les mécanismes de
négociation collective ainsi que les
organisations d'employeurs et de
travailleurs et constitue en ce sens un
affaiblissement de la liberté syndicale
et de la négociation collective à
l'encontre des principes des conventions
87 et
98 ce comité n'est pas le porte-parole
du Parti communiste français ou
d'organisation syndicale que vous jugez
réfractaire à toute réforme il est
composé de neuf membres titulaires
provenant des groupes gouvernement
employeur et travailleur et il est
présidé par une personnalité
indépendante pourtant il estime comme
nous que l'inversion de la hiérarchie
des normes et surtout la remise en cause
du principe de faveur quoi que vous en
disiez madame la ministre encore
aujourd'hui nuit fortement à la qualité
du dialogue social ce qui est néfaste
tant pour les syndicats que pour les
entreprises si bien qu'en adoptant ce
projet de loi nous sommes en infraction
par rapport à la Convention 87 de l'OIT
sur les libertés syndicales et à la
Convention 98 relative à la négociation
collective nous sommes également en
infraction par rapport au Pacte des
nations- Unies relatif aux droits
économiques sociaux et culturels à ce
titre le rapport établi par les experts
du Comité des droits économiques sociaux
et culturels et sans appel je le cite le
comité est préoccupé par les dérogations
à des protections acquises en matière de
conditions de travail proposé par le
projet de loi travail y compris pour
accroître la flexibilité du marché du
travail sans qu'il ne soit démontré que
l'État a considéré toutes les autres
solution poss possible plus loin le
comité exhorte l'État français à
s'assurer que toute mesure rétrograde
concernant les conditions de travail est
inévitable et pleinement justifié
nécessaire et proportionné à la
situation et non discriminatoire
pouvez-vous nous assurer madame la
ministre que ces précautions ont bien
été prises par l'État je ne le pense pas
le simple fait que N n'ayez pas pris le
temps de la concertation avec les
organisations syndicales en est une
preuve vous n'avez pas exploré toutes
les solution possi pour créer de
l'emploi et adapter de manière
progressiste le droit du travail aux
évolutions économiques et sociales comme
la réduction du temps de travail par
exemple exploré pourtant il y a peu par
un rapport de Ligas mais il est vrai que
ce rapport ne vous a pas été transmis
vous avez accepté les propositions du
mdeef tandis que vous refusiez des
écouter cell des organisations
syndicales qui sont au côté des des
salariés et connaissent la réalité de
l'entreprise to tout comme vous n'avez
pas écouté les représentants des petites
et moyennes entreprises qui anticipent
les conséquences catastrophiques pour
leurs entreprises de ce nouveau dumping
social de ce fait nous refusons en tant
que parlementaire de participer à cette
destruction d'acquis sociaux reconnu au
niveau international nous invitons les
sénateurs et sénatrices qui n'ont pas
soutenu notre motion en première lecture
parce qu'ils pensaient encore que le
dialogue était possible à vootter avec
nous l'irrecevabilité de ce texte de
plus si nous n'avons pas la possibilité
d'exercer seul un recours auprès du
Conseil constitutionnel nous vous
invitons mes chers collègues à vous
joindre à nous pour contester sur la
base des éléments que je viens d'exposer
la constitutionnalité de ce texte il en
va du respect par la France de ses
engagements internationaux de son
histoire et des valeurs qui fondent
notre République je vous
remercie merci Madame David quel est
l'avis de la
commission merci madame la Présidente
bon écoutez je crois que cet après-midi
effectivement nous aurons le même
objectif rejeter le texte mais nous
n'utiliserons pas les même moyens euh
vous avez défendu une motion
d'irrecevabilité une question préalable
sera défendue après ce qui permettra
d'écouter les orateurs des différents
groupes et et leur point de vue
naturellement sur sur le texte en tous
les cas on peut vous reconnaître la
constance puisque vous aviez défendu
effectivement cette une telle motion euh
en première lecture et donc constance et
cohérence ont régulièrement été au
rendez-vous je dois le dire au sein du
groupe CRC comme comme comme au sein des
groupes républicains udi d'ailleurs he
je dois le dire même si voilà nous ne
partageons pas euh les mêmes les mêmes
idées pour essayer d'en finir avec cette
fatalité d'un chômage de longue durée
qui qui qui qui qui s'allonge de plus en
plus alors par rapport aux arguments que
vous avez mis en avant euh vous évoquiez
effectivement le non respect de
l'article L1 bon l'article L1 ça pas été
madame la
ministre respecter totalement bon bref
le Conseil d'État s'entire avec une
pirouette mais l'article 1 n'est pas
encore de niveau constitutionnel il y a
il y a l'idée ici ou là qui existe de le
mettre au niveau constitutionnel pour
empêcher effectivement que se reproduise
ce type de de situation donc je pense
pas que d'un point de vue
constitutionnalité il y ait de problème
par ailleurs vous évoquez effectivement
la conformité du texte à un certain
nombre d'engagements internationaux euh
le à la Constitution et à des
engagements internationaux je vous AZ
écouté attentivement effectivement vous
évoquiez l'OIT le PACT euh et si je
reprends l'avis du Conseil d'État
justement euh de ce point de vue-là je
je le cite hein sur deux points il
précise les des choses le Conseil d'État
a vérifié que les dispositions du
présent article et notamment la
détermination du champ de la négociation
collective et des dispositions
supplétives ne comportait pas de risque
d'incompétence négative du législateur
et ne privit pas de garantie légale
l'exigence constitutionnelle formulé par
le préambule de la constitution de 46
donc je pense que de ce point de vue-là
juridiquement les choses sont bordées de
la même façon que pour l'article 11 elle
a le Conseil d'État estimé compatible
avec la convention 158 de l'OIT la les
modalités de rupture euh de rupture du
contrat de travail donc pour toutes ces
raisons à titre personnel j'émettrai un
avis défavorable à cette motion que
notre commission avait déjà rejeté en
première lecture mais voilà les
explications que je voulais vous
apporter je vous remercie quel est
l'avis du Gouvernement madame la
ministre merci madame la Présidente
c'est également un avis défavorable je
vais j'ai donné quelques arguments tout
à l'heure s'agissant du comité d'experts
de de l'ONU je vais leur adresser un
courrier justement en réponse donc je
vous tiendrai également destinataire de
de ce courrier mais ce qui m'étonne et
et notamment sur le sens de l'écoute sur
le sens du dialogue le gouvernement n'a
eu de cesse d'écouter de modifier et
d'apporter un nouvel équilibre à ce
texte c'est d'ailleurs ce qu'on nous
reproche et on dit est-ce qu'on s'écoute
est-ce qu'on s'entend mais dans votre
intervention à aucun moment à aucun
moment vous ne mettez en valeur aussi
des avancées teles que le compte
personnel d'activité tel que la garantie
jeune tel que le contrat saisonnier sur
lequel par exemple vous personnellement
vous vous êtes aussi battu et je crois
que si nous sommes arrivés à une telle
tension aussi dans le débat public c'est
aussi parce que chacun dans nos
expressions nous n'avons pas toujours
fait preuve de beaucoup de nuances
est-ce que le CPA est-ce que le contrat
saisonnier est-ce que la réaffirmation
du rôle des branches c'est un retour au
19e siècle non je ne le crois pas et
nous avons un débat qui n'est pas
médiocre sur la place de la négociation
collective c'est un vrai débat et je
l'ai dit tout à l'heure c'est en effet
un clivage politique mais c'est aussi un
clivage syndical que nous voyons cette
question là et donc moi je reste
persuadé aujourd'hui que ce système et
que cette la loi doit bien sûr rester
protectrice mais que elle ne permet pas
de nous adapter à toutes les situations
et que le contrat la négociation plus
près du terrain permet d'améliorer les
choses sans rien enlever des droits des
salariés et c'est pour moi essentiel
donc pour toutes ces raisons c'est un
avis
défavorable merci Madame la Ministre y y
a-t-il des explications de
vote je n'en vois pas je mets au voix la
motion numéro 19 de Monsieur Dominique
vatrin et les membres du groupe
communiste républicain et citoyens
tendant à opposer l'exception
d'irrecevabilité je rappelle que
l'adoption de cette motion entraînerait
le rejet du projet de
loi qui est
pour qui est
contre qui s'abstient la motion n'est
pas
adoptée dans la suite de la discussion
générale la parole est à Madame Nicole
brick pour le groupe socialiste et
républicain
bonjour nous achevons le périple
parlementaire de la loi travail celle à
laquelle madame la ministre votre nom
restera attaché alors tout cela peut
paraître quelque peu décalé en regard du
drame national que nous vivons mais nous
ferons notre travail de Parlement aire
jusqu'au bout ou presque et ce sera
notre manière à nous démocratiquement de
rendre hommage aux victimes des attentat
sur notre sol en Europe et dans le monde
alors la majorité sénatoriale choisit
d'interrompre la course parlementaire du
texte du Gouvernement on peut comprendre
sa
motivation à quoi bon nous dit-elle
refaire le débat que nous avons eu il y
a 3 semaines à quoi bon puisqu'il y a eu
le 493 à l'Assemblée nationale c'est un
point de vue ce n'est pas le nôtre car
il y a encore à dire pour
faire d'abord parce que le gouvernement
a modifié son
propos en amendant le texte à l'article
1 ce n'est pas une mesure symbolique que
d'associer le Haut Conseil du dialogue
social aux travaux de la commission
d'experts chargé de la réécriture du
Code du travail c'est la garantie d'une
réflexion collective de la mise au clair
des points d'accord et de désaccord
entre les partenaires sociaux ce n'est
pas rien à l'article 13 de définir les
objectifs de la négociation de branche
salaire minima classification garantie
collective complémentaire mutualisation
des fonds de la formation
professionnelle de prévention de la
pénibilité et d'égalité professionnel
entre les hommes et les femmes ce n'est
pas rien de revoir l'adaptation des
stipulations nation des accords de
branche au niveau local par des
négociations territorialisées c'est une
vision décentralisée que nous aurions pu
partager ce n'est pas rien d'engager
avant le 31 décembre de cette année une
négociation portant sur la définition de
l'ordre public conventionnel applicable
dans une branche cette démarche met les
partenaires sociaux devant leur
responsabilité où ils se saisissent des
opportunités ouvertes par la rédaction
ultime de la loi où il fuit leur
responsabilité et je ne crains pas de le
dire ils seront balayés par
l'histoire ces modalités ne sont pas des
contreparties messieurs les rapporteurs
au fameux article 2 qui prévoit en
matière de temps de travail la primauté
de l'accord d'entreprise la la
contrepartie vous le savez c'est
l'accord c'est majoritaire prévu à
l'article 10 ce que la majorité
sénatoriale a refusé ou n'a pas compris
son sens alors vous n'êtes pas les seuls
c'est le vrai de ce côté-ci et c'est
vrai de ce côté-là et j'ai plaisir j'ai
plaisir régulièrement à lire très
attentivement le bulletin d'une partie
importante du MDEF l'Union des
industries des métiers de la métallurgie
et dans le dernier
bulletin je vois je lis et je vais me
faire le plaisir de le cit
pourquoi disent-ils les rédacteurs ne
pas reconnaître que le principe
majoritaire constitue un garde-fou
efficace contre l'éventualité improbable
d'accord au Rabet je crois que tout est
dit par rapport à la vision symétrique
de l'article 2 et de l'article 10 alors
cette question vaut pour tout le monde
ensuite vous ne voulez pas discuter des
articles parce que vous considérez que
les points de vue sont irréconciliables
entre le Sénat et l'Assemblée une
lecture complète aurait pourtant la
pédagogie aidant montré des points
d'accord qui ne sont pas mineurs et je
veux en citer quelques-uns sur le
parcours d'accompagnement personnalisé
pour les salariés refusant les accords
collectifs défensifs et offensif c'est
l'article 11 et vous y avez mis la patte
sur les groupements d'employeurs où
notre collègue il daudign a beaucoup
travaillé et a été beaucoup entendu par
le gouvernement et sur un point majeur
qui la médecine du travail et Madame
Génisson qui la connaît bien s'est
exprimé lors de notre précédent débat et
nous aurions pu ensemble défendre la
création d'une procédure d'appel des
commissions régionales des médecins du
travail car nous sommes très dubidatifs
et nous l'avons dit sur le recours
direct au
prudom nous avons aussi des
convergenceces certaines sur le travail
détaché c'est dommage que nous n'ayons
pas pu aller plus loin en commission
monsieur le rapporteur le mooine vous
avez fait un trait
d'esprit vous êtes coutumier du genre et
vous avez voulu en faire un tout à
l'heure que j'ai trouvé quelque peu
condescendant à l'égard de Madame la
Ministre quand vous avez dit qu'elle
était commise d'office écoutez elle a
passé au Sénat nombre d'heures à faire
de la pédagogie à convaincre à écouter
et moi j'ai cru
ici comme dans les médias il décelit une
volonté farouche de faire de ce texte le
sien donc je crois pas que on puisse
dire qu'elle est commise d'office mais
s'agissant de
moi vous avez vous avez en commission
donc relevé ma présence à une réunion
tenue la veille au soir qui était un
meeting d'un jeune ministre alors mais
merci de vous occuper de mes soirées
mais ce qui m'intéresse c'est le fond du
texte et quand vous citer ce jeune
ministre Emmanuel Macron pour ne pas le
citer il faut le citer dans sa vérité et
dans son texte non mais je crois que
c'est important et je veux les remettre
ces propos car ça intéresse notre débat
et notamment l'avenir de ce débat que
nous disait-il le travail se transforme
et nous devons en avoir conscience
parlant de la réforme du travail il dit
c'est une réforme à laquelle je crois
que je défends mais ce n'est plus le
combat d'aujourd'hui parce que le
travail a radicalement changé et il
ajouté nous sortons de l'âge classique
du travail je reprends la parole pour
dire qu'il est dommage que la droite
sénatoriale refuse d'explorer davantage
les voix esquissé par la loi concernant
la numérisation de l'économie et le
schéma d'hier c'est une conviction que
nous avons c'est l'économie
fordiste verticale celui d'aujourd'hui
c'est déjà celui du numérique et nous ne
restaurerons pas l'ordre ancien
l'économie numérique accomplira le
découplage de la couverture sociale et
du contrat de travail elle recré donc
cette économie nouvelle la mise en place
d'institutions nouvelles pour
accompagner les nouvelles formes de
travail et ces institutions doivent
rendre le nouveau modèle social inclusif
et soutenable c'est ça que nous devons
faire et c'est ça qui exquisse quelque
part le projet de loi pour preuve
l'article
21 l'article 21 qui jette les bases de
ce nouveau modèle avec le compte
personnel d'activité et je voudrais
aussi rappeler qu'en parallèle à notre
débat parlementaire il y a eu la
négociation sur assurance chômage qui du
fait patronal il faut le dire a échoué
mais elle pourra reprendre je pense mais
il y a quelque chose de très important
qui a été c'est l'accord de branche sur
les intermittents et je veux m'y arrêter
un instant car il
prévoit que en contrepartie d'une
assurance chômage spécifique l'usage du
CDD n'est pas limité en clair qu'est-ce
que cela signifie pour les intermittents
une protection sociale et pour leurs
employeurs forcément multiples la
capacité de bénéficier d'une main
d'œuvre qualifiée et flexible ce
peut-être une voie d'avenir bien
préférable à mes yeux que le chimérique
revenu universel car à n'en pas douter
c'est la protection sociale qui sera une
nouvelle frontière de nos débats en
France et nous la souhaitons aussi
groupe socialiste en Europe je rappelle
que lors des élections européennes nous
avons mis au premier rang d'un agenda
social européen la couverture de
l'assurance chômage notamment pour les
jeunes et c'est une voie d'avenir je
pense que la France donne au travers de
cet accord
alors je dois aussi tirer c'est normal à
la fin de ces 4 mois de débat public et
nous j'espère que vous la tierez avec
moi une leçon pour l'avenir et elle
tient à la gouvernance toute réforme de
cette importance doit respecter trois
enjeux démocratiques la démocratie
sociale vous en avez longuement parlé
c'est leprit de la
loi la démocratie d'opinion ça
compte maintenant c'est comme ça et elle
doit aussi user de la démocratie
politique et le
493 madame David n'est pas le problème
car il a sa légitimité démocratique
pourquoi parce qu'il oblige
l'opposition à fournir à montrer qu'elle
est capable
d'avoir de constituer une majorité
alternative et en cela le 493 est un
principe démocratique alors je voudrais
aussi citer pour l'avenir est très
proche celui-là s'agissant de ces trois
démocraties qu'il faut réunir le rapport
Laurent vous connaissez Monsieur Laurent
qui a remis un trava très important
au gouvernement sur le temps de travail
dans la fonction publique et le débat
couvre le gouvernement avec les
syndicats et les employeurs ces
conclusions devraient être remises en
décembre de cette année et ce sera un
test de l'exercice démocratique madame
la ministre on nous annonce 127 décrets
c'est ça et donc pour l'application de
cette loi c'est beaucoup et nous savons
d'expérience que quelquefois les décrets
prennent des détournements avec l'esprit
de la loi alors je ne saurais trop vous
recommander je ne saurais trop vous
recommander d'avoir à cette
occasion un esprit d'association avec
pour le moins ceux qui soutiennent ce
texte la majorité qui soutient ce texte
toute assemblée confondu d'être associé
à ces décrets parce
que il faut arriver il y a une partie
importante qui est d'application directe
mais il y a beaucoup encore à faire et
je souhaite qu'effectivement nous
puissions nous retrouver à la fin du
parcours car je crois que cette loi
comporte les prévenirs d'un nouvel
avenir
social merci Madame
brick la parole est à Monsieur Jean de
zessard pour le groupe écologiste madame
la présidente madame la ministre
monsieur le Président de la Commission
monsieur le rapporteur chers
collègues ce projet de loi se propose
d'accroître la place du dialogue social
et de développer une véritable culture
du compromis et de la
négociation pourtant il laisse
apparaître une
contradiction dans la mesure où il
s'agit d'une loi sur le dialogue social
qui est contestée par une partie
importante des
syndicats et comment promouvoir
la logique de compromis lorsque le débat
parlementaire est conclu par une
utilisation répétée de l'article
493 une réforme d'envergure du droit du
travail implique un consensus minimal
entre les acteurs de la négociation
collective et je vous renouvelle mon
interrogation madame la ministre
pourquoi bouleverser le droit du travail
à un an d'échéance électorale au risque
de fracture politique
profonde évidemment la droite
sénatoriale s'est engouffrée dans la
brèche et en cas
d'alternance nous craignons que les
gardesfous que vous avez pris soin de
bien définir soit
balayé le projet de loi que nous
examinons aujourd'hui est effectivement
celui adopté par l'Assemblée nationale
en application de l'article
493 ce n'est plus la version
caricaturale proposée par le Sénat au
mois de juin ainsi les 35 heur ont été
rétablis le plafonnement des indemnités
prudomales a été supprimé le périmètre
des licenciements économiques repensé
les dispositifs qui suscitaent notre
intérêt la garantie jeunes et le compte
personnel d'activité ont retrouver de
leur
substance il faut le saluer la version
qui nous est aujourd'hui proposé
pourrait être qualifié de moins pire
seulement organiser les relations de
travail en ce contentant du moins pire
est
insatisfaisant surtout lorsqu'on connaît
les conséquences de la vie
professionnelle sur la vie privé des
salariés en ce sens l'article 2 est
particulirement symbolique en effet les
règles relatives au temps de travail
auraiit vocation à être déterminé à
l'échelle de
l'entreprise si nous nous comprenons et
vous et nous vous l'avons dit Madame la
Ministre l'importance de développer le
dialogue social de proximité il nous
semble indispensable de tenir compte du
contexte économique actuel aujourd'hui
la contrainte économique pèse fortement
sur les salariés et comment négocier
librement dans la crainte de perdre son
emploi nous refusons donc la dynamique
de ce projet de loi si de nouvelles
libertés sont concédées aux entreprises
elles ne sont pas assorties de nouvelles
protections pour les salariés d'ailleurs
on remarque que l'idée de protection a
disparu de l'intitulé du projet de loi
en effet si la flexibilité n'est pas
sortie d'une sécurisation des parcours
professionnels et de garantie pour
l'emploi où est la modernisation du
droit du travail dans une course au
moins 10 ans social où la norme
reviendrait à s'aligner sur les plus bas
salaires et conduirait à l'absence de
sécurité de l'emploi de plus madame la
ministre vous ne parvenez pas à nous
démontrer que cette flexibilité accrue
sera génératrice d'emploi bien au
contraire Alain Supiot éminent
spécialiste du troit du travail a
récemment rappelé que les travaux de
recherche conduit à l'échelle mondiale
tendent à prouver que des standards de
travail élevés favorise la qualité de la
main d'œuvre et favorise la qualité de
la main d'œuvre qu'ils ont un qu'ils ont
sur l'emploi un effet soit neutre soit
positif donc des standards de travail
élevés ont des effets positifs pour
l'emploi et plutôt que de favoriser la
précarisation accrue du salarié je suis
convaincu par l'idée qu'il faut
privilégier une main d'œuvre de qualité
le contexte actuel est un contexte de
dumping social je sais vous n'y croyez
pas madame la ministre mais il faut
regarder la réalité en face la course
moins disant social et est perdu
d'avance en effet d'autres pays moins
soucieux de la protection des salariés
pourront toujours surenchérir et ainsi
encore diminuer le coût du travail et ce
quel que quel qu'en soit le prix pour
ces salariés et plutôt que de nous
enliser dans un combat perdu d'avance
dont le seul résultat serait la
régression des avanés sociales
développons et misons sur nos atouts le
savoir-faire la formation les public les
infrastructures la qualité de vie le
droit du
travail doit aussi
anticiper la transition énergétique de
demain et intégrer dès maintenant les
normes
environnementales pour conclure nous
pensons que des Assises du droit du
travail auraient permis sur le fond
comme sur la forme de travailler
ensemble sur un nouveau droit du travail
ambition et producteur et protecteur
malheureusement ce n'est pas le cas et
ces assises auraient évité le passage en
force syndicale et politique d'une loi
sur le dialogue social je vous
remercie remerci chers collègues la
parole est à Monsieur Dominique vatrin
madame la présidente madame la ministre
messieurs les rapporteurs mes chers
collègues ce qui s'est passé en Dee
lecture à l'Assemblée nationale confirme
en tout point ce que les parlementaires
communistes dénoncent depuis le début un
passage en force contre la majorité des
syndicats représentant la majorité des
salariés contre la majorité
parlementaire car pas de majorité à
l'Assemblée nationale pour voter ce
texte c'est bien ça le sens du
493 contre la vie majoritaire des
Français et la mobilisation de plusieurs
millions d'entre eux sur le fond il
s'agit d'une nouvelle étape dans la
fuite en avant ultralibérale ce texte
répond en premier lieu aux exigences du
meddeef et du patronat européen relayé
par la Commission de Bruxelles sous
forme de recommandation dont les grand
titre se retrouve quasiment tel quel
dans le contenu des articles et
l'argumentaire gouvernemental en
inversant la hiérarchie des normes en
affaiblissant encore le principe de
faveur en rendant toujours plus virtuel
les 35 heures légales vous avez ouvert
un boulevard à toutes les surenchères
possibles la droite sénatoriale c'est si
engouffré dans les sillons du texte pour
voter la possibilité de faire travailler
les salariés 37 38 ou 39 he payer 35 he
pour la plupart d'entre eux sans parler
de la flexibilisation encore plus
poussée de la modulation du temps de
travail des licenciements ou du
doublement des seuils sociaux le texte
qui nous revient de l'Assemblée
nationale est en définitive quasiment le
même que celui que nous avons combattu
ici à trois petites exceptions près à
l'article 1er aux alignats 3 et 4 de
l'article 13 certains diront madame la
ministre en premier puis madame brick
que la nouvelle formulation de ce
dernier article conforte les branche
mais l'alinéa 4 est pourtant très clair
le principe de faveur serait respecté
mais je cite à l'exclusion des thèmes
pour lesquels la loi prévoit la primuté
de la convention ou de l'accord d'entre
prise aujourd'hui donc la durée et
l'organisation du temps de travail
serait exclu du principe de faveur et
demain tout le code du travail quelle
avancée en réalité vous vous êtes
enfermé dans un système de pensée qui
démontre malheureusement chaque jour sa
faillite l'argument du MDEF selon
lesquel les entreprises n'embauchent pas
par peur d'une soi-disant impossibilité
de licencier alors que 360000 ruptures
conv
ont été constaté en 2015 et même devenu
un argument de
l'exécutif pourtant vous continuer
d'ouvrir toujours plus grande les Vanes
du libéralisme ainsi demain le seuil de
déclenchement des heures supplémentaires
le rémunération mais aussi le travail de
nuit travail du dimanche et j'en passe
deviendront des sujets de négociation
local là où les salariés sont les plus
isolés les moins organisés selon un
sondage hiob du 17 juin dernier vous
avez même poussé si loin le bouchon
qu'une majorité d'artisans et de chefs
de petites entreprises s'oppos à votre
projet craignant une course au dumping
social et rappelant à juste titre le
rôle de régulation des branches pour une
saine concurrence pourtant il est
possible et nécessaire de faire évoluer
le code du travail dans le sens de
nouvelles réponses aux évolutions
technologiques économiques et sociales
nombre des 402 amendements que le groupe
CRC a défendu en première lecture
dessinait les contours d'une autre
approche du travail de nouvelles
régulation au pouvoir encore trop
puissant des intérêts financiers contre
l'intérêt collectif dans la vie des
entreprises nous avons proposé de
moderniser le code du travail en
réduisant le temps de travail à 32 he
nous avons proposé de sanctionner les
licenciement des entreprises qui
réalisent des bénéfices or plutôt que de
les interdire ou au moins de les réguler
vous aviez dans un premier temps voulu
les faciliter encore plus en excluant de
l'appréciation des difficultés
économique les entreprises situées hors
territoire national nous avons également
proposé de donner de nouveau pouvoir
d'intervention salarié dans les
entreprises et une meilleure
représentation dans les conseils
d'administration comme cela se fait
d'ailleurs en Allemagne mais vous avez
préféré limiter les droits existants en
restreignant le recours à l'expertise
pour les représentants du personnel
alors que nous vous nous vous avons
proposé de lutter contre les
discrimination syndicale dans les
entreprises euh nous sommes au regret de
constater madame la ministre que vous
avez vous êtes passé outre la décision
de l'inspection du travail en autorisant
le 27 juin le licenciement d'un délégué
CGT de sexo au prétexte que certains
salariés avaient continué une grève
après la signature d'un accord de fin de
conflit cela ne va pas dans le bon sens
madame la ministre mes chers collègues
je l'ai déjà dit mercredi dernier en
commission nous sortons de 80h de débat
avec aussi un grand regret car au-delà
de nos divergences et points de vue
fondamentalement différent sur le cœur
de ce projet de loi il aurait été
possible à partir de certains articles
de commencer à avancer sur un certain
nombre de sujets le groupe CRC a formulé
de multiples propositions sur les
questions du temps partiel des
travailleurs saisonniers de l'amande de
la lutte contre travail détaché illégal
quasiment aucune n'a été reprise au
prétexte que ici il y aura une
négociation et des ordonnances là il
faudrait attendre la renégociation d'une
directive européenne sans rien faire
d'ici là ou là encore un plan
ministériel dont personne ici n'a eu
connaissance en refusant la case du code
du travail et en faisant les
propositions alternatives le groupe CRC
n'a été ni immobiliste ni passéiste mais
au contraire moderne combatif et fidèle
aux valeurs de la gauche sachez que nous
restons mobilisés au côté des salariés
et nous vous donnons rendez-vous ici
même à la rentrée pour continuer à
porter les exigences et les aspirations
du monde du
travail merci chers collègues la parole
est à Monsieur Bruno
retaillot madame la présidente madame la
ministre mes chers collègues vous me
permettrez de commencer par des
remerciements pour exprimer notre
gratitude au président de notre
commission des affaires sociales aux
trois rapporteurs Jean-Baptiste leemoine
Jean-Marc gabouti et Michel Forissier
ils n'ont pas ménagé leur temps ils
n'ont pas compté leur peine ils nous ont
élaboré un texte qui est un vrai texte
réformateur je sais qu'ils sont déçus
que le gouvernement n'a pas montré plus
d'ouverture mais ce que je veux leur
dire c'est que ce travail ne sera pas
perdu et que je n'en doute pas il ouvre
des perspectives pour l'avenir si cela
peut les les
rassurer madame la
ministre madame la ministre nous sommes
vous êtes nous sommes au terme de ce qui
aurait été sans doute pour vous un
parcours du
combattant je ne vais pas vous adresser
de félicitation parce que dans quelques
minutes je je dirais ce que je pense du
texte et je n'en pense pas que du bien
pour euh filer la métaphore de Madame
brick il y a à dire et je j'ajoute qu'il
y a même à redire mais vous me
permettrez d'exprimer au nom de mes
collègues
euh une forme de respect pour la
façon que vous avez eu de soutenir vos
positions vous l'avez fait sans
sectarisme vous l'avez fait avec
beaucoup de pédagogie vous l'avez fait
avec conviction permettez-moi de vous
dire j'ai trouvé souvent des attaques
qui ne sont pas venus du Sénat de
l'extérieur injuste et je pense que vous
connaissez parfaitement votre dossier
euh et vous l'avez fait avec une forme
d'élégance malheureusement
malheureusement madame l'élégance ne
suffit pas à rendre le texte aimable et
et je pense que nous nous trouvons c'est
la raison pour laquelle mon groupe
évidemment votera la question préalable
nous nous trouvons devant une formidable
occasion manquée vraiment vraiment je
pense que nous sommes devant un de ces
textes qui resteront et qui restera un
texte un peu emblématique de l'échec de
ce gouvernement à ne pas trouver le
chemin d'une vraie réforme alors que la
France a tant besoin de réforme et elle
a besoin de réforme pour deux raisons
fondamentales la première c'est que
d'habitude vous savez il y a sans doute
que le Président de la République pour
se satisfaire de la situation actuelle
d'habitude on dit toujours que lorsqu'on
se compare on se console mais quand on
compare la situation économique de la
France à la situation économique des
grands pays européens des pays
occidentaux on ne se console pas on se
désole depuis 2012 depuis 2012 quelle
est la performance française en matière
de croissance
elle est plus de moitié moindre à la
moyenne des pays de l'OCDE en 2012 sur
le plan du chômage nous étions sur 28 à
l'époque et encore au 14e rang 2012
aujourd'hui pour le chômage nous sommes
au 21e rang première raison qui fait que
la réforme n'est pas une option elle est
nécessaire une autre raison tout aussi
fondamentale c'est que vous avez
bénéficié d'une fenêtre de tir d'une
fenêtre historique pour porter votre
réforme quelle est-elle cette fenêtre
c'est ce que nous avons appelé c'est ce
que le président de la République plutôt
a appelé l'alignement des planètes non
pas comme une astrologie mais pour
constater que jamais depuis de longues
années et encore pour de longues années
à venir nous n'aurons bénéficié d'une
situation économique aussi Cléante sur
les taux d'intérêt sur l'euro sur le
coût des matières premières et du
Pétrole et vous aurez gâché cette
occasion historique on peut féliciter
Mario dragi qui est un excellent
président de la Banque centrale
il pratique ce qu'on appelle
l'assouplissement monétaire pour une
seule raison
pour donner un peu d'élasticité aux
différents gouvernements pour leur dire
saisissez-vous de l'occasion que je vous
donne parce que c'est une occasion rêvée
pour pouvoir réformer parce que le
quantating eing l'assouplissement
monétaire ça ne peut-être une occasion
favorable qu'à la condition qu'on
réforme sinon ça peut créer de graves
problèmes y compris en Europe y compris
dans
l'eurozone et pour autant cette réforme
aura été gâchée avant même d'ailleurs le
dépôt du texte avant même le dépôt du
texte vous aurez retiré tout ce qui
concernait le plafonnement le barem pour
les indemnités prud deal au cours de
l'examen du texte notamment par nos
collègues députés vous aurez été de
recul
successif en
renoncement bien sûr il reste l'article
2 qui qui est un des articles
emblématique mais que reste-t-il de cet
article corseté terriblementcadré
avec les accords de branche avec
l'article 13 notamment donc voyez non
seulement cette réforme aura été vidé je
pense très sincèrement et je m exprimé
que notre groupe à l'époque
Jean-Baptiste lea dit tout à l'heure
était prêt à soutenir la première
version de votre texte qui partait d'une
bonne intuition cette version là c'était
une chance pour l'emploi madame la
version initiale le texte final
finalement ce sera une nouvelle
complexité française parce que non
seulement le texte aura été vidé de sa
substance aura été en quelque sorte
neutralisé qu à son ambition
réformatrice mais en plus il va se
traduire par de nouvelles lourdeurs
pensez donc 127 décrets
d'application complexité
française je pense sincèrement que pour
expliquer ce résultat décevant
malheureusement je pense que c'est
d'abord la
conséquence d'un problème de méthode
d'une erreur de méthode et c'est aussi
la conséquence je crois d'une approche
idéologique l'erreur de
méthode c'est que je crois que une
réforme pour aboutir doit réunir des
conditions et vous
savez le reproche que je vous adresse là
je pourrais aussi l'adresser à ma propre
famille politique par le
passé mais je pense que le parcours
chaotique de ce texte restera là aussi
comme un exemple à ne pas suivre pour
celles et ceux qui demain
devront le voudront-ils mais devront
réformer la France trois exemples d'reur
de méthodes premier exemple la
démocratie c'est le consentement sans
mandat clair du peuple vous ne pouvez
pas mener une réforme ambitieuse ça
n'est pas possible vous pouvez pas à la
fois assumer le discours du budget du
Bourget et en même temps changer de pied
quelques temps après parce qu'alors là
c'est l'élongation et c'est le claquage
deè deuxème exemple en matière de
méthode on fait les réformes au début
pas à la fin je me souviens d'une
déclaration du candidat François
Hollande en 2012 ses mots étai les
suivants les bonnes idées il faut les
faire en début de mandat pas à la fin
malheureusement il ne s'est
pasblliquer cette maxime à son propre
mandat et puis un autre point c'est que
il faut donner du sens à une méthode
est-ce que la méthode a été portée
est-ce que la méthode vous l'avit porté
c'est vrai la méthode a-t-elle été
expliquée le texte a-t-il été remis dans
une perspective si vous voulez mobiliser
un peuple vous devez donner du sens vous
donner resituer une réforme dans un
ensemble plus large pour dire aux
Français aux Françaises là où vous
voulez aller quelle est la lueur que
vous vous espérer faire lever à
l'horizon de l'avenir et et je pense que
faute de cette
méthode vos efforts ont été
vains mais finalement du coup il faut
pas s'étonner de ce que votre
majorité se soit fracturé profondément
fracturé vous remarquerez au passage et
je voudrais remercier aussi bien le
groupe centrist que le groupe que j'ai
l'honneur de présider vous remarquerez
que nous avons uni la majorité a été
cohérente pour proposer un vrai texte de
la majorité senatoriale nous avons vu
ici même avec parfois quelques
étonnements votre majorité se
diviser vous avez finalement vous vous
êtes mis la France à dos la France de
gauche celle qui consiste celle qui
considère en tout cas que le code du
travail est intouchable c'est une sorte
de totem qu'il faut surtout pas y
toucher quel qu'en soit d'ailleurs les
fruits amers
vous vous vous êtes mis aussi une grande
partie des Français à dos tous ceux et
celles qui vous faisaient confiance qui
croyaient en votre enfin en tout cas
entre votre volonté votre ambition
réformative et qui ont été finalement
déçu et à un moment ou un autre mais
nous avons l'habitude vous avez tenté de
trouver un coupable idéal les sénateurs
le Sénat de droite et du centre on
commence à être habitué on nous avait
fait le coup aussi pour la déchéance ça
devient sorte de comique de répétition
et ça n'a pas marché pensez donc le
Sénat ultralibéral nous qui voulions
aller jusqu'à sortir des 35 he vous
imaginez nous qui voulions dans nos
rêves les plus fous imaginer ce qu'un
premier ministre qui n'était pas Premier
ministre à l'époque en 2011 avait
proposé lors des primaires de la gauche
manuel Vals la sortie des 35h que nous
assumons alors qu' un certain nombre de
d'articles que vous avez inscrit dans ce
texte déguise finalement des
accommandements avec les 35 heur nous
nous l'assumons clairement et nous
disons pourquoi nous l'assumons parce
que nous considérons que le chômage
c'est le concer de la société française
voilà de façon très nette et claire
erreur de
méthode erreur de méthode et enfin une
approche idéologique datée une approche
idéologique dépassé je pense que vous
vous êtes fait rattraper je pense que je
ne personnalise pas du tout mon propos
et je pense que collectivement vous vous
êtes fait rattraper par les vieilles
lunes de la gauche par de vieilles idées
des idées qui appartiennent au 20e
siècle pas au 21e siècle cette idée que
l'entreprise est est nécessairement une
sorte de tension dialectique entre le
travail et le capital que nécessairement
l'entreprise est un territoire de
conflit alors que nous pensons que c'est
une communauté
d'intérêt que nous avons voulu
réaffirmer d'ailleurs avec un un certain
nombre de dispositions comme la
participation et l'intéressement que
vous avez très très partiellement de
façon facultative d'ailleurs reprise à
votre compte mais en ayant cette
conception de l'entreprise peut-être pas
vous madame personnellement mais le
texte emporte la marque
emportant cette conception conflictuelle
de l'entreprise vous êtes passé à côté
du problème majeur français qui est que
la peur de l'embauche la peur de
l'embauche crée des millions de chômeurs
en France première erreur idéologique
autre erreur idéologique le fait
d'accepter de façon définitive une
organisation duale du marché du travail
les outsiders et les insiders on
renforce sa protection de ceux qui ont
un emploi au détriment de ceux qui n'en
ont pas c'est le problème endémique de
la France c'est ce qui crée ce que
d'autres ont appelé une sorte de
préférence française pour le chômage de
masse et bien tant que nous sortirons
pas de cette dualité nous enfermerons
les plus fragiles dans une fatalité qui
est terrible et enfin autre erreur
idéologique franchement qu'est-ce que
pèse la généralisation de la garantie
jeune auprès des 20 articles qu'a
proposé Michel forer la gauche montre
que vous êtes hostile à l'apprentissage
si vous n'aviez pas été hostile à
l'apprentissage vous aviez vous auriez
repris un certain nombre de dispositifs
dans ma région sur 10 apprentis en a
qui quelques mois après leur formation
sont intégrés
dans le monde du travail et je suis sûr
que des collègues de gauche comme
évidemment les collègues de droite
portent cette idée que la
l'apprentissage ça n'est pas une voie de
garage c'est la voie du succès alors
pourquoi ne l'avoir pas traduit pourquoi
avoir préféré une sorte de revenu
d'assistance pour les jeunes plutôt que
de leur mettre les pieds le pied à
l'étrier pour une vraie insertion
professionnelle c'est
incompréhensible pour terminer pour
terminer madame ce ce texte
malheureusement ce texte malheureusement
n'apportera aucune solution à ce que
nous considérons comme un malheur
français malheureusement ce texte
n'apportera aucune adaptation que notre
économie que notre droit du travail doit
prendre en compte alors même on le voit
que beaucoup de gouvernements
socio-démocrate en Europe on fait ce
travail d'adaptation si nous ne le
faisons pas nous condamnons la France de
façon définitive l'économie française a
une dégringolade qui sera lente mais qui
sera absolument certaine voilà vous
aurez finalement mis la France dans la
rue pour peu de choses pour peu de
choses ou pour presque rien et vous
aurez donné un écho particulier à cette
phrase d'Edgar fort la France est
toujours en avance d'une révolution
parce que la France est toujours en
retard d'une réforme
merci
la parole est à Monsieur François
zooketto pour le groupe udi Union
centriste
rebonour madame la présidente madame la
ministre mes chers
collègues chacun sur nos bancs sur S bon
souhaite à de rares exceptions près la
fin de l'examen de ce
texte Cean justifie pas par la volonté
d'une promulgation
rapide en réalité nous espérons tous la
fin de l'examen de ce texte car elle
marquera pour un temps seulement sans
doute malheureusement mais elle marquera
la fin de longs mois de tensions
sociales et politiques et dans le
contexte que chacun connaît nous n'avons
pas nous n'avions pas besoin de ces
tensions votre projet madame le ministre
n'avait que très peu de chance d'aboutir
telle que vous l'aviez imaginé ce pour
plusieurs raisons l'un principal était
c'est un manque de préparation le
gouvernement n'a pas pris la mesure de
la défiance des partenaires sociaux à
son encontre après une succession de
réforme mal engagé et d'échec politique
une défiance d'ailleurs largement
partagée par nos concitoyens en ne
consultant pas suffisamment en amont en
ne négociant pas suffisamment tôt en ne
respectant pas complètement l'article
1er du Code du travail vous avez donné
une occasion à notre pays d'exprimer
l'un de ces travers bien
connus ce manque de préparation s'est
également manifesté sur un plan plus
politique dès la présentation de ce
texte vous n'aviez pas de majorité pour
défendre ce texte à l'Assemblée
nationale cet épisode a d'ailleurs
démontré une fois de plus que la
majorité formée par François Hollande au
début de son quinquena n'avait qu'un
sens relatif et que l'unité de la gauche
était un moment
fugitif la gauche que vous avez invoqué
tout à l'heure n'a pas non plus pris la
peine de clarifier sa vision de
l'entreprise c'est ce qui ressorti très
clairement des tensions que nous avons
observé entre lesffondeur et le groupe
socialiste ou avec le Parti socialiste
aussi ici même nous avons été le les
témoins au Sénat
entre les idées défendues par Madame
brick et celles défendu par Madame
linman chacun conviendra qu'il y a un
monde en plus d'un manque de préparation
ce texte a souffert d'un manque de
pédagogie d'cun dans notre pays se
refuse à tout changement par peur par
intérêt par conformisme peut-être ils
ont d'embla contesté votre projet de loi
qui dans sa philosophie original en tout
cas impliquait de vraies évolutions qui
étaient attendu il faut bien le dire
nous les attendions en matière de droit
du
travail ces personnes qui s'opposent
systématiquement savent utiliser
l'opinion publique pour défendre leur
position elles savent mobiliser savent
jouer sur les peurs sur les frustrations
et elles ne font preuve d'aucune retenue
lorsqu'il s'agit de contester la moindre
réforme et bien madame les ministres
avec le gouvernement vous n'avez pas su
les contredire vous n'avez pas su
expliquer à nos concitoyens vos
objectifs votre conception du monde du
travail votre conception de la
négociation collective de la médecine du
travail et je pourrais évoquer d'autres
termes vraiment une meilleure
préparation un effort de présentation
d'explication aurait permis à ce texte
d'arriver plus solidement au Parlement
vous aurez beau nous rappeler le nombre
d'amendements retenus en commission et
dans la version considérée comme adopté
la réalité est que le débat n'a pas eu
lieu à l'Assemblée nationale qu'il
s'agissait d'un dialogue de Sour le
Sénat quant à lui vous a démontré qu'un
vrai débat démocratique est possible ce
débat a eu lieu pendant 10 jours dans
notre hémicycle vous avez pu défendre
votre texte nous avons pu nous majorité
sénatoriale Unis en effet exprimer et
défendre nos positions et ce ne sont pas
aussi nos collègues du groupe CRC qui
ont pu déposer et défendre plusieurs
centaines d'amendements qui diront le le
contraire le débat a eu lieu au Sénat
nos rapporteurs dont je salue
l'implication la qualité du travail ont
suici proposer une version abouti de
votre texte
enrichi par les propositions non
seulement des groupes de la majorité
sénatoriale mais également par celle de
l'opposition sénatoriale le texte voté
au Sénat n'était pas plus dur il n'était
pas plus libéral comme on a pu le lire
ça et là la caricature est facile sur
ces sujets lorsqu'on reste dans les
postures en fait caricature elle permet
de faire l'économie d'une vraie
analyse non ici en se basant sur la
philosophie de votre projet initial et
sur le rapport
combrexel ce texte du Sénat a su lié
souplesse simplicité et efficacité je
crois d'ailleurs que c'est Jean-Marc
gabouti qui utilisait ces terme lors de
l'examen en première lecture nous avons
ainsi adapté la définition du
licenciement économique pour que
l'effort ne repose pas uniquement sur
les salariés nous avons souhaité en
effet encourager intéressement nous
avons souhaité développer
l'apprentissage nous avons souhaité
moderniser la médecine du travail et
aussi et surtout je dirais donner encore
plus de marge de manœuvre aux accords
d'entreprise parfois l'entreprise sera
le cadre à privilégié dans certaines
matières dans d'autres il s'agira de la
branche dans d'autres encore c'est la
loi qui doit trouver toute son
efficacité mais sachons adapter notre
monde du travail n'ayons pas peur du
dialogue social même lorsqu'il est
direct
malheureusement et l' s'y
attendait l'action du Sénat a été
entièrement déconstruite par l'Assemblée
nationale et la version que vous nous
soumettez aujourd'hui est peu ou prou
identique à celle qui nous avait été
transmise en première
lecture et bien au groupe udi UC madame
la ministre nous considérons qu'il est
aujourd'hui essentiel à la lumière de
cette expérience de revoir notre façon
de gouverner et de légiférer et je pense
que cette expérience en effet sera utile
pour tous il nous faut revoir nos
méthodes la défiance de nos concitoyens
à l'encontre des responsablebles
politique nous oblige en effet à changer
il faut sortir du temps médiatique il
faut prendre de nousveau le temps
surtout sur des questions essentielles
comme celle que nous traitons
aujourd'hui il faut prendre le temps de
travailler efficacement méthodiquement
il faut expliquer au préalable ce que
l'on va faire et à forceori il ne faut
surtout pas faire comme malheureusement
vous l'avez fait ce que vous n'aviez pas
à annoncé et même parfois l'inverse de
ce qui avait été annoncé il s'agit là de
la principale leçon des discussions de
ce texte qui est un échec sur bien des
aspects l'objectif initial de votre
projet était de permettre aux 5 millions
de Français au chômage de retrouver le
chemin de
l'emploi cet objectif malheureusement
s'est rapidement effacé au profit de
querelles idéologiques et de calcul
politique pour ces diverses raisons vous
comprendrez bien que nous ne voterons
pas ce texte et nous voterons à
l'inverse la motion tendante à opposer
la question préalable je vous
remercie la discussion générale est
close madame la ministre vous vouliez
prendre la parole
oui merci madame la Présidente je vous
rassure pour ceux qui ont suivi les 80
heur de débat je vais pas reprendre
l'ensemble des arguments mais euh
quelques éléments néanmoins et je
voudrais répondre justement à la
question qu'a posé le président
reetaillot et le sénateur de cessar
pourquoi une réforme la dernière année
du
quinena parce que un président est élu
pour 5 ans et un président quand il est
élu depuis 5 ans il mène des réformes de
2012 à 2017 et surtout quand notre pays
en a besoin nous avons fait de
nombreuses réformes nous avons fait la
loi de sécurisation de l'emploi en 2 13
et la négociation autour des PSE nous
savons c'est un sujet particulièrement
sensible mais nous avons réussi dans ce
cadre là nous avons fait la loi de
modernisation du dialogue social nous
avons fait la réforme de la formation
professionnelle en effet dans le champ
du travail et de l'emploi il y a eu une
loi tous les ans mais parce que nous
sommes attachés à notre modèle social à
un moment il faut aussi être en capacité
d'être lucide sur la situation de notre
pays aimer son pays c'est aussi prendre
ses responsabilités face au défi immense
qu'il attend et donc le choix c'est
l'attachement à notre modèle social et
donc s'adapter s'adapter pour ne pas
faire disparaître ce qui fait notre
modèle social et lorsque nous regardons
en effet que nous sommes le deuxième
pays utilisateur de CDD de moins d'un
mois de l'Union européenne nous savons
bien que dans notre pays il y a un
problème pour faciliter l'emploi durable
c'est un problème essentiel et c'est
pour cela moi je l'ai assumer ici je
n'ai pas une vision maniquienne de
l'entreprise et malgré les débats malgré
les tensions je garde la même vision je
pense en effet que notre pays doit
avancer et aller vers cette culture de
la négociation cette culture du
compromis et nous l'avons anticipé le
Premier ministre a demander il y a plus
d'un an au printemps 2015 un rapport à
Jean-Denis com brexel sur la part de la
négociation d'entreprise et à partir de
ce rapport nous le président Milon l'a
suffisamment dit tout au long des débats
beaucoup de rapports sont au ministère
du Travail si nous n'avions pas tenu les
enseignements de ce rapport que nous
aurais-je reproché que nous commandons
des rapports pour évacuer les sujets non
il faut assumer les choses et assumer
notamment que dans notre pays le
contournement au droit du travail les
contournements sont nombreux nous voyons
bien le travail détaché se répend le
travail indépendant se répend également
et nous voyons également que l'intérim
se répand c'est ça l'enjeu et donc
pourquoi apporter plus de place à la
négociation c'est pour donner cette
capacité justement à mieux nous adapter
dans un monde qui bouge très vite et je
considère en effet que c'est par le
dialogue social au plus près de
l'entreprise avec les gardes-fous que
nous avons posé et notamment le principe
majoritaire qui est pour moi essentiel
dans ce projet de loi c'est avec ces
gardes de fous là que nous arriverons
justement à mettre progrès social
progrès économique dans un même
mouvement ce qui nous permet de nous
adapter tout en préservant notre modèle
social
et puis il y a aussi dans ce texte des
avancées qui sont essentielles 30 ans
dans notre pays que nous disons que la
formation professionnelle ne bénéficie
pas à ceux qui en ont le plus besoin
poser un droit universel à la formation
abonderz les comptes des salariés les
moins qualifiés développer la formation
des demandeurs d'emploi développer la
garantie jeune moi je n'opposerai jamais
l'apprentissage à la garantie jeune je
suis bien sûr une défenseur de
l'apprentissage C emplois 7 jeune sur 10
trouve un emploi d'ailleurs 20 ans que
c'était tabou on ne voulait pas ouvrir
les titres professionnels du ministère à
l'apprentissage je l'ai fait en 6 mois
et vous le savez en tant que président
de région vous avez reçu mon courrier
c'est quelque chose qui est aujourd'hui
développé et qui est essentiel parce que
pour une partie des jeunes cela permet
de répondre mais la garantie jeune ce
n'est pas une allocation ce n'est pas
une allocation la garantie jeune je l'ai
toujours dit c'est surtout pas cela
c'est un dispositif d'accompagnement
c'est un contrat gagnant entre le jeune
et la mission locale et ça leur permet
de d'être mis en situation
professionnelle c'est tout sauf une
allocation
et pourquoi alors oui vous avez raison
monsieur le sénateur Zeto il y a eu des
erreurs de pédagogie je les ai assumé je
en première lecture j'avais l'occasion
de le dire je continue à les assumer
pleinement en effet mais vous le voyez
bien que certes le conflit politique
l'arrivée les élections dans un an mais
aussi elle repose sur des visions
différentes d'un point de vue des
organisations syndicales ce n'est pas
pour rien qu'elles ont refusé la
négociation autour du rapport de
jean-deni brexel et c'est ces ces
difficultés dans cette ces analyses
différentes dans le front syndicale
elles ne sont pas nouvelles n ne
racontons pas d'histoire vous vous
souvenez le débat autour des retraites
complémentaire à l'automne dernier vous
savez bien que cette une organisation
syndicale a décidé de boycotter depuis
de nombreuses années les conférences
sociales vous savez bien que sur les
anis depuis de nombreuses années
certaines organisations syndicales ne
signent pas les annis donc ne
réinventons pas non plus un décor
parfait où tout le monde s'entendrait
particulièrement bien et tout le monde
serait en capacité de trouver ensemble
les solutions non nous avons touché à
des visions différentes des visions
différentes et je ne suis pas là en
train d'opposer le culte de la loi avec
le contrat non je crois que dans notre
pays nous avons besoin justement d'avoir
la loi le code du travail d'avoir
également des conventions des branches
beaucoup plus fortes si nous devons
restructurer les branches c'est bien
parce que la négociation n'est pas
suffisamment dynamique et puis nous
avons aussi la négociation au sein des
entreprises alors de quoi avons-nous
souffert également mais de propos aussi
caricaturaux quand j'entends encore la
semaine dernière un jeune dire avec
cette loi travail les apprentis vont
travailler 60 Hees par semaine comment
voulez-vous lorsque nous défendons tous
l'intérêt général quand il y a une telle
une telle posture tel propos justement
caricaturau comment voulez-vous
justement gagner la bataille de
l'opinion bien sûr il y a eu des erreurs
du gouvernement je les assume pleinement
mais je considère que le compromis que
nous avons trouvé à chaque étape
notamment avec des organisations
syndicales qui soutiennent ce texte et
d'ailleurs monsieur le sénateur vatrin
dans votre expression je vois souvent
que vous oubliez aussi que certaines
organisations syndicale soutiennent ce
texte mais sincèrement ce texte est tout
autre chose qu'un retour au 19e siècle
ce texte c'est justement une confiance
dans le dialogue social et en même temps
des nouveaux droits des nouveaux droits
pour nous adapter donc bien sûr bien sûr
quand on regarde les choses on aurait
bien sûr aimé espérer que les choses se
passent différemment
néanmoins néanmoins je suis sûre que
quand les droits quand le compte
personnel d'activité sera ouvert pour
certains de nos salariés de nos
concitoyens quand les travailleurs les
artisans les commerçants auront droit à
la formation dès janvier 2018 quand nous
aurons autant de jeunes qui trouveront
un emploi parce que ce sont les jeunes
les plus précaires justement qui sont
visés grâce à la garantie jeune lorsque
dans le cadre des contrats saisonniers
nous améliorerons le sort des
saisonniers je suis persuadé que les 5
mois que nous avons vécu et qui vont
peut-être se poursuivre ben seront
derrière nous et c'est ça aussi le sens
de l'État le sens de l'intérêt général
c'est de continuer aussi à avancer
lorsqu'on croit à son pays je vous
remercie merci madame la ministre nous
passons à la discussion de la motion
tendant à opposer la question préalable
messieur Jean-Baptiste Lemoine Jean-Marc
gabouti et Michel fuissier au nom de la
commission des affaires sociales ont
déposé une motion distribuée sous le
numéro 1 tendant à opposer la question
préalable au texte en discussion
Monsieur Alain Milon a maintenant la
parole pour défendre la
motion madame merci madame la présidente
madame la présidente madame la ministre
messieurs les rapporteurs mes chers
collègues nous arrivons donc au terme de
l'examen par notre assemblée d'un projet
de loi dont le contenu tout comme
l'intitulé ont fortement évolué durant
depuis que ces premiers éléments ont été
rendus publics en début année lors de sa
réunion du 13 juillet dernier notre
commission a approuvé sur proposition de
ses rapporteurs auquel je souhaite ici
rendre hommage le dépôt d'une motion
tendante à opposer la question préalable
à ce texte pourtant dans un contexte
social tendu le Sénat et ça a été dit a
procédé à l'examen approfondi de ce
texte en première lecture après que nos
collègues députés en ont été privés par
le gouvernement en raison du recours à
la proc de l'article 49 aléa 3 de la
Constitution la commission des affaires
sociales je vous le rappelle a consacré
le 1er juin dernier près de 13h à
l'examen du projet de loi et à
l'élaboration de son texte sur 411
amendements déposé 201 avaient été
adoptés dont 155 émanant des rapporteurs
ceci avait réalisé au préalable un
travail de concertation exhaustif dans
des délais très courts plus d'une une
soixantaine d'organismes d'experts et de
représentants des partenaires sociaux
avaient été entendus en moins d'un mois
notre commission avait également reçu
successivement les organisations
syndicales et patronales représentatives
ensuite le Sénat a consacré plus de 80
heures soit 2 semaines complètes à
l'examen du texte en séance publique sur
les 909 amendements examinés dont 368
pour le seul groupe CRC 157 ont été
adoptés dont 15 de ce même groupe ces
statistiques démontre que le Sénat était
animé par une volonté sincère de se
montrer à la hauteur des enjeux de ce
projet de loi le texte issu de notre
assemblée traduit de ce fait fidèlement
les orientations politiques de sa
majorité et de la commission quels
étaient les principaux apports du Sénat
ù outre les points mis en exerg par nos
rapporteurs il faut souligner que nous
avons cherché à renouer avec l'ambition
initiale de ce texte tel qu'elle
ressortait de l'avantprjet transmis au
Conseil d'État alors salué par tous ceux
qui cherchent à donner un nouveau
souffle à l'économie française de plus
nous étions mus par la volonté de lever
les obstacles identifiés de longue date
dont souffrent nos entreprises et qui
sont un frein à l'emploi surtout nous
voulions enrichir le texte des
réflexions conduites par le Sénat depuis
plusieurs années sur des sujets aussi
varié que le mandatement les accords de
compétitivité ou encore la formation
professionnelle force est aujourd'hui de
constater que l'Assemblée nationale et
le gouvernement n'ont pas pris au
sérieux nos propositions une thématique
illustre tout particulièrement la
désinvolture avec laquelle les députés
et le gouvernement ont examiné le texte
du Sénat je veux parler de
l'apprentissage sur proposition de notre
rapporteur Michel Forissier dont on ne
peut mettre en doute la connaissance du
sujet compenu de sa longue expérience
professionnelle en la matière notre
commission avait complété le texte par
12 articles visant à répondre au défis
auxquels fait face aujourd'hui
l'apprentissage ils étaient issu de la
proposition de loi qu'avait rédigé notre
collègue ellisabeth Lamur pour la
dégation atorial aux entreprises afin de
développer l'apprentissage comme voie de
réussite au terme d'un long processus
d'échange avec tous les acteurs
concernés ministère du Travail et de
l'éducation nationale chambre consulaire
partenaires sociaux région cette
démarche reposait sur un diagnostic très
largement partagé l'apprentissage en
France fait face à de nombreux obstacles
institutionnels culturels et financiers
qui l'empêche d' uper la place qui
devrait être la sienne dans notre
société notre commission avait
d'ailleurs pu constater en avril 2015
lors d'un déplacement sur ce thème en
Allemagne et en Autriche que des
réformes de bon sens et consensuelles
permettraient de surmonter
cesulté pourtant toutes les mesures que
nous avons adopté ont été balayées d'un
revers de main par les députés sans même
qu'il daigne en retravailler certaines
ou faire des propositions alternatives
j'aimerais en cité trois à titre
d'exemple tout d'abord la création d'un
pacte national pour l'apprentissage sur
le modèle allemand de l'Alliance pour la
formation initiale et continue nous
semblait indispensable ce pacte aurait
organisé l'indispensable coordination de
tous les acteurs concernés sur la base
du volontariat sans remettre en cause
les prérogatives de chacun en
particulier des régions si un État comme
l'Allemagne parvient à concilier son
organisation fédérale avec un pilotage
national de l'apprentissage pourquoi
notre pays n'y parviendrait-il pas
ensuite la formation des élèves sur les
métiers aujourd'hui pour le mieux
lacunaire devait selon nous être
amélioré c'est pourquoi nous avons
proposé que les jeunes qui élaborent un
projet d'orientation vers
l'apprentissage puissent bénéficier dès
l'obtention du brevvet et sous statut
scolaire du dispositif d'initiation au
métier en alternance le DIMA enfin
compte tenu du taux élevé de rupture
prématurée du des contrats
d'apprentissage qui dépasse les 30 %
dans certaines filières nous nous étions
inspiré de l'exemple alsacien pour
rendre obligatoire la médiation
consulaire préalablement à toute rupture
d'un contrat d'apprentissage il est
profondément regrettable que de telles
propositions ai été écarté sans
discussion au-delà de la question de
l'apprentissage la plupart des apports
du Sénat ne figurent plus dans le texte
qui nous a été transmis qu'il s'agisse
de la simplification et de la
sécurisation du cadre juridique
applicable aux entreprises du
renforcement de leur compétitivité de la
prise en compte des spécificités des TPE
et PME ou encore de la réaffirmation des
mission de la médecine du travail dès
lors vous comprendrez aisément qu'il ne
nous paraît pas nécessairement opportun
de soumettre ce projet de loi à une
nouvelle lecture alors que la position
de notre assemblée
peut être largement développée en
première lecture mais n'est pas en
mesure de faire davantage évoluer un
texte sur lequel le gouvernement devra
sans doute demain engager pour la
troisème fois sa responsabilité pour
faire adopter par l'Assemblée nationale
en lecture définitive nous voici arrivé
au moment de dire à ce gouvernement non
nous ne sommes pas d'accord avec votre
projet de loi pas d'accord avec le fond
pratiquement qui n'existe pratiquement
plus et pas d'accord avec la forme voilà
une loi qui aura cette particularité
d'être applicable alors qu'elle n'aura
été votée ni par l'Assemblée nationale
victime d'un 493 autoritaire ni par le
Sénat victime de votre volonté de ne
rien retenir ni sur les idées
excellentes qui qui auraient pu être
positive même si elles étaient
polémiques ni sur l'apprentissage où
nous avons montré une voie pragmatique
de possibl réussite ENF voilà un moment
paradoxal mes chers collègues où après
avoir tant critiqué le président Sarkozi
pendant 5 ans et son Premier ministre
François Fillon sur leur autoratarisme
alors qu'ils n'ont jamais utilisé le 493
jamais eu le moindre heure dans la rue
et jamais mis en danger la renommée
internationale de de notre pays vous
nous apprêtez à mettre en place une loi
refusée par le pays tout entier refusée
par le patronat les salariés les
travailleurs après avoir attisé les
rancœurs entre le privé et le public
vous nous montrez combien ce
gouvernement tient peu de compte des
demandes du pays ça va mieux paraît-il
ça n'est pas la réussite d'un événement
sportif réussite identique à celui de
1998 qui améliorera le moral du peuple
français vous nous parlez certains
membres du gouvernement nous parlent
souvent de la 6e république si celle-ci
est à l'image de ces derniers mois
autant garder la 5e si selon vous il
s'agit pour cette 5e République d'un
coup d'état permanent ce coup d'état
permanent c'est votre gouvernement et
son premier ministre en particulier qui
le dirige et qui le met en place pour
conclure Madame la Ministre malgré
l'estime que je vous porte et vous le
savez et j'adhère complètement au propos
de notre président rotillot à votre
sujet j'invite le sinat à voter la
motion que vous soumets la commission
des affaires
sociales madame la ministre oserais-je
vous demander votre
avis défavorable madame la
Présidente il y a-t-il des explications
de vote je n'envoie pardon Monsieur
Laurent je vous en prie
oui je voudrais dire pourquoi le groupe
CRC ne votera pas la question préalable
déposée par la droite sénatoriale parce
que nous n'en partageons aucune des deux
motivations la première elle est
évidente implicite c'est l'esprit de
surencherre qui vous a animé dans le
débat sur la première lecture du texte
noncant de pousser les feux de cette loi
que vous avez soutenu dont vous avez
soutenu le principe dès le premier jour
au côté du
mdeef vous avez cherché à en rajouter
tout au long du débat dans le sens de la
du démantèlement des garanties
collectives et du Code du travail vous
ne vouliez pas combattre l'article 2
vous vouliez pousser sa logique jusqu'au
bout comme ça a été rappelé tout à
l'heure par le le rapporteur le moine et
bien c'est évidemment cette logique que
nous combattons depuis le départ et donc
nous ne pouvons pas voter la question
préalable au nom de cette motivation la
seconde motivation de la question
préalable on voit bien que c'est une
petite habileté politique qui vous évite
en vérité le vote final sur la loi vous
ne voulez pas voter contre cette loi et
donc vous préférez
utiliser l'arme de la question préalable
en quelque sorte vous voulez cette loi
mais vous ne voulez pas laisser vos
empreintes sur la scène du crime et et
vous utiliser cela qui est une manière
en fait de donner un blancin au texte
gouvernemental tel qu'il est sorti de
l'Assemblée le résultat évidemment c'est
un dénis de démocratie supplémentaire
puisque ce texte n'aura jamais été
discuté en séance à l'Assemblée avec 2
493 et il n'aura été discuté qu'une
seule fois en séance au Sénat c'est donc
un texte majeur qui n'aura connu qu'une
seule discussion en séance dans les deux
hémicycles et Madame la Ministre à
propos du 493 vous nous dites que vous
n'avez pas obtenu de compromis avec la
droite et voilà pourquoi aujourd'hui il
n'y a pas de poursuite du débat au Sénat
mais vous n'expliquez toujours pas
pourquoi vous n'en avez pas obtenu avec
votre majorité parlementaire ni en
première lecture ni en 2e lecture et
c'est bien là le problème et ça nous
donne à l'arrivée un état assez piteux
de notre démocratie puisque nous allons
adopter un texte majeur sans qu'en
vérité il est il n'est jamais obtenu de
bout en bout de majorité parlementaire
alors pour ce qui nous concerne vous
savez que les organisation syndical qui
combattent ce texte ont annoncé qu'elle
poursuivrait la mobilisation et bien
nous resterons à leur côté et nous
continuerons de porter cette voix dans
l'hémicycle dès la
rentrée bien
je vais maintenant mettre au voie la
motion numéro 1 de mieur le moine
gabouti et
foriciier qui au nom de la commission
des affaires sociales tendant à opposer
la question préalable je rappelle que
l'adoption de cette motion entraînerait
le rejet du projet de loi j'ai été
saisie d'une demande de scrutin public
par la commission des affaires sociales
sur la motion tendante à imposer à
opposer pardon la question préalable je
vous rappelle que l'avis du Gouvernement
est défavorable il va être procéder au
scrutin public dans les conditions
fixées par l'article 56 du règlement le
scrutin va être ouvert dans quelques
instants scrutin est ouvert si le
résultat du scrutin numéro
439 nombre de votants
342 nombre de suffrages exprimés
341 pour l'adoption
187 contre
154 le Sénat a adopté la question
préalable par conséquent il n'a pas
adopté le projet de loi en nouvelle
lecture voilà pour le débat des
sénateurs sur la loi travail en nouvelle
lecture un débat tronqué puisque les
sénateurs ont choisi d'adopter une
motion posant la question préalable
présenté par la majorité sénatoriale et
permettant de rejeter le texte
directement après la discussion générale
le parcours législatif de la loi alcomer
est finalement terminé le lendemain
mercredi avec le 493 une troisème fois
présenté par le gouvernement qui lui
permet d'engager sa responsabilité et de
se passer du vote des députés vous
pouvez toujours voir et revoir toutes
les séances sur notre site
publsenat.fr très bonne journée sur les
chaînes
parlementaires